brother, what's up, Misk? How's it going? We're doing politics
right now. I don't know if you're going to agree with the with
the politics. Okay, come come back when we're covering Teone.
All right, we're covering something even shockingly slightly
grosser than Techtown. More gross than Tetown even. I know it's
it's terrible to say. I don't care about politics. Well, listen.
I already did my Techone segment. I'm waiting on you, man.
You got to go live.
Yes. [__] Teeone. Absolutely.
Are you going live? When are you going live?
I will. Okay. We need you to go live, man. We need you live now.
We need all the details.
Live and live. We're going to be ready for it, man. We're ready
for it. We're covering this stuff. We're ready for it. We're
hyped.
Watch that video first. Okay. That video is fantastic. All right.
That video, if you want to get that guy on a call, I I know that
guy. That guy definitely get on a call. Okay,
let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. We are an alliance now. Okay.
like-minded individuals. Okay. Let's do it. Thank you very much,
Miz. We're We're here with you. Okay. We can take this guy down.
This guy's no good.
>> All right. Very cool. Notice how nobody around him is
talking about it him today despite always talking about these
>> I will say I find it very interesting that Misk, sorry,
that Asmin Gold is not speaking about it. that he didn't want
to say anything at all. I have noticed, you know, Mythic Talent
dropped him. Not a lot of defenders out. There are some defenders,
though.
I think they might just realize I'm guessing people, you know,
talking behind the scenes, too. People like, "Yeah, this guy,
this guy's kind of
Yeah, we've been calling it out. Keep calling out how botted
LSF is, by the way. We're we're standing behind you on that.
Okay. We saw we saw a bunch of clips with your name in it getting
downvoted massively. All right. Like the biggest drama. the biggest
drama of the past like two years comes out. One creator sent
somebody to to write down notes for another creator's lawsuit
and that doesn't even get play on LSF. Man, what the going on?
What's going We need to shut down LSF until we can figure out
what the hell is going on there. Okay.
We got to figure it out.
Okay. So, unfortunately, the demonic nature of
>> the demonic nature of the Trump administration will
have to hold because we're on to a different kind of demon. Okay?
A demon that is on our side. We're on to a different kind of
demon.
>> Don't ever let anyone take you down, chat. Stand up
for yourself. It's something I didn't do for years. That I'm
a idiot for doing it because I let everyone think they have an
opportunity to just constantly [__] on me and do
things when I won't fight back. I'm a [__] idiot.
>> I should have fought back the second anyone ever said
anything about me. I'm a dumb and I listen to people that I shouldn't
have who said be quiet.
>> Always stand up for yourself, chat. Always. I get that
there's a lot of stuff going on right now at the ice in Minneapolis
or what's happening. Totally get it. So, um you know, that's
why I'm going to keep releasing it so that way they have to see
it at some point to make sure that they do. I'm not going to
put it all out at once. I'm going to drag this out in a bloody
cold murder to make sure that they completely see the realities
of who Tech Tone is just in case for some reason they only read
the headlines and they don't read the full subscription. Just
in case they don't like to read the whole clip or watch many
things, say they don't want to pay attention to it or they're
not paying attention to it because they've got other stuff going
on. I'll make sure you can't lie and say that you didn't see
it. So today we're going to release some things. Tomorrow I might
might release more and the big time coahuna is going to be when
they get the transcripts and you can see the realities of who
Techton is. I also find it hilarious how some people are trying
to claim it's just civil court. I want to show you some loser
who I really question who the you are named Chibi. You [__]
disgusting [laughter] loser who claims uh anyways if what you
said was true there would be public records. So at this moment
it's lies or slander.
Oh my god, bro. You think I'm lying that I sent someone there
to a courtroom and filmed Tecton walking out with a with a a
a tuxedo on? You think I made that up? Like, where do you think
What do you think? Did Tek go to a wedding that I just cooked
that from? Like, what the are you on about? He went to court.
He lost, buddy. You want to know why it's not the transcripts
yet? It's Friday. >> And look, I'm talking because mine
are just allegations and lies. People are seeing the truth and
realizing that there just a few streamers teamed up to take me
down. watch my stream tonight and realize how bad your buddy
was and realize this is just the start. Chat, I'm not kidding
you. People are realizing what I'm saying and they're realizing
I'm not some. You want to know why this is 100 likes and I don't
want to talk about likes despite the fact that everyone thinks
that's all I care about. I care about it a lot but not that much.
My tweets a month ago were getting 100 likes. When people want
to claim that I'm a vile human being, say I salted Emiru. When
Emu's thing is not salt, that is not salt. That is me reading
the room wrong. That's it. I went back to her house. Her house
she brought me to. Not No, no, no. Not I anything in the street
or anything weird. We got back together that night. We went to
her house and started to kiss
because we went to dinner together and we were talking about
getting back together and let's try it. We went to her house.
We started kissing. I read the room wrong. I jumped up like a
cat just like she said and I left.
That's it. That's exactly what Emmy said. Okay.
So let's listen to that story of assault where Asmin Gold attacked
me for four days straight made six different videos, millions
of views and berates me to the point where now my YouTube channel
is losing subs every day and I'm losing followers everywhere
I go and I had to go to kick because of it
>> and I get called a when I go to bars >> because
of people >> who just attacked me non-stop for that accusation
then tried to use clips of me when I got mad that she had moldy
cheese in the fridge like THAT MATTER. EMIRU IS NOT A LIAR. Emiru
is not a liar. Don't call Emu a liar. >> You can have two
different reactions to that situation. It's your job as the third
party to be unemotional about it. Okay, those two people have
totally different reactions and I can understand >> Do
not talk [__] about Emmy. Okay, >> is a real
problem. Techone talks to Asmin all day. Techone is buddy buddy
with him and rides his
as said a single word and he says he doesn't want to.
There's a clip of it. He says he doesn't want to talk about it.
Interesting. Why would you want to talk about mine, which is
just allegations? It's a he said, she said, but you're willing
to talk about You're not willing to talk about
You claimed you didn't want to talk about Lucari when he had
a link on his computer.
Why? Why would you want to talk about it? Why would you want
to go into it? Why would you want to do what you do with everything
and stick your nose in it? Why?
It doesn't make any sense. Why would you not talk about Teone
and Lucari when they have actual bad accusations when all mine
was was just allegations that I'm a bad boyfriend?
But you ruined my life. But you won't talk about Teone.
>> I get it. You probably have to go. Do you know? Do you
remember how many Twitter posts there were of him talking about
you into the void for a whole year? There's a whole list. Oh,
I know. I have the whole list. I have a whole doctrine of techone
with defamation in case he tries anything. By the way, I'm prepared.
I've been prepared for this for a long time. I have everything
that Tech has ever said about me written down just in case he
wants to try something and I will go sue him to a wall because
I will make sure that guy doesn't speak a damn word. >> What
can they even do? Mark Cardi, we are a swarm and not just me
but so many other content creators. So many other content creators
he's been ruining the lives of for years.
Years. >> Tech tone dog. Okay, get ready guys. We need
to juice that. Okay,
you you ready? We're gonna show We've been doing drills on this.
We got to juice this. Okay, let me go grab it. We've been doing
drills is why you got to participate. >> All right, >> you
need to give Bisk your >> I find it funny. People are like,
I I didn't send anyone.
I didn't send
>> It's insane.
The guy I sent is right
>> It's Axian.
>> He was there. HE WAS THERE. OH, TWEETING TWEET. Let's
go. >> Give Miz your energy, guys. lose your
>> Axi had with two hours of sleep went and I called him
in the middle of the night >> and I said, "Axi, you got
to go." >> And he went >> Oh, [__] >> And
he got two hours of sleep.
>> And he was able to take this picture. >> Shut
off alerts, guys. Okay, we're going to shut off alerts for the
segment. >> Seven hours he was on. He was on there getting
me information.
>> Let's go. >> Did you tell Pink to contact your
lawyers about Tech's tweet? I did. I have I have not at all.
I'll tell you me and my me and my relationship with Pink.
Pink came to me about a year ago to
tell me that she's sorry that Teone went around and told people
I shook her hand really long and was inappropriate and was weird
and that I am uh touchy and
>> All this drama is great content. I don't think it's
fully drama, but I understand it's insanely good content for
you guys. I understand that people like this stuff. And to me
personally, I'm not going to lie to you when I say that I'm enjoying
it, too, because I hate Tech Tone. Uh I hate when >> Oh,
you think so, bro? I went back and counted his dance party last
night was like 30 minutes uh with like 12 songs. Okay. His dance
party after his stream, he did like 12 different songs. He did
We Are the Champions, Sounds of Silence.
He did so many songs, dude. truth about >> Yeah. No, the
reality of Techon is that he assaulted Pinkchu. That the reality
is that Pinkchu tweeted about it a year and a half ago and all
those hash believe all victims didn't believe Pinkchu despite
the fact that she had descriptive details of assault and how
terrible he was and how she just tweeted it on her alt account.
They didn't want to believe a word she said, right? But you'll
believe Emaru. You'll believe other women, but you won't believe
Pinku. Want to know why? Cuz she has an only fans.
That's it. She has an only fans. Call her a Say she's a [__]
Say she's a and she and she she and she's making this up for
crap. >> Do not do that. He's making a point. Do not do
that. She makes more money than most people I know combined.
Pink Chu is one of the biggest Instagram girls right now on Only
Fans. She's
insanely popular.
Insanely popular. She makes millions. And when I millions a month,
>> I I don't know about that. Wait, who's Pingshu again?
Oh, wait, hold on. Somebody sent me this context for who Pingu
is. This is Pingu apparently. So, she like travels.
>> She like travels or something.
>> WAIT, WE HAD THE SAME STRATEGY? NO WAY. >> 6.8
MILLION VIEWS. >> God damn it. >> This was posted
two days ago.
>> There's no way. There's no way we have the same strategy.
>> You don't think she's making crazy amounts of money?
>> Is he going to show the goth girl clip? >> I seen
her on Normy's site. She's insanely successful. And you know
when she became insanely successful girl when she stopped dating
Techto.
>> Yeah. Teto,
man. >> Grow Care Bears. What do you know?
>> But Miss K, you did the SAME THING TO AMARU. [laughter]
I haven't seen her grow like this.
Yeah, but Miskf was much worse at stifling Emir's growth. Okay,
can we send this guy a video of like Techone crying or something
to get his energy >> Henny got so drunk. >> I need
>> that. Uh >> I need that second experience like
last night. I need it. I need it. >> Uh Henny got so drunk
we got kicked out of the bar because she by accident tried to
go to the bathroom and went into the men's bathroom instead.
And um she got so drunk that I walk outside and she's on the
ground. So, I have to like try to pick her up and like hold her
in my hands. Uh, and then while I'm doing that, someone came
up to me and like, "Are you Miskf?" And I said, "Yeah." And he
goes, "Tean
is bad. Let's go,
dude. No way. Let's
>> Yep. It's happening, boys." I'm telling >> some
dude next some dude's next to me in the urinal. He checks out
my and he nods to me and he says, >> "I'm telling you,
>> techone, brother." Teone, nice, by the >> I'll
never pretend I'm perfect. >> I'll never pretend that I'm
some angel. I'm not. I'm not an angel. I've done [__]
dumb. I've done stupid.
>> I I have But I'm learned from my lessons and I continue
to move. >> Techone is not someone that's learned anything.
People like Teeone will continue doing their thing and acting
the way they act until they're forcibly stopped by court. Okay?
And I have not ever acted the way Tech Tone acted in what I have
for you today. Okay.
I've treated people like I have. I would say when I say I treated
people like it's more so I've uh put my career first instead
of them.
And I think that was wrong uh in a lot of ways. And I did it
to my old best friends of like 25 years. I put my career first
and I stopped going on Discord and talking to them and hanging
out with them. I focused on my my my growth. And while it was
worth it in some ways, it also damaged my friendship. But I've
recouped that because I've said like I've learned, you know.
But is it anything that's like not life lessons and things you
learn in real life? It's No, it's not. You've most definitely
treated people bad, but I feel like you're becoming a better
person. Absolutely. I I have treated people bad. Everyone has.
Wouldn't you have treated people bad before and you've learned
and you're trying to become a better person? That's all I care
about is if you're trying to become a better person and learn
from your mistakes and grow. That's human. being a human. You
know, people want to pretend have to be some angels. We don't
because we're human as well. >> I think we're gonna see
like a quo amnesty. Okay, he's gonna like let that one go so
we can focus on the big devils. All right. >> Supposed
to be perfect.
>> You learn, you admit you're wrong, and you move on.
to grow. You know,
>> slowly moving from >> like I I only like dating
girls that really cared about my career because
I liked that
>> we were doing the same thing because I would use them
for content, you know? That's truly I I'll be honest, like I
would use girls for content all the time and I liked being in
relationships with girls for content that were also content creators
cuz I can use them for content.
Um, but I can't use a doctor. Watch a quick 1-hour video on Techone.
Apparently, and I quote, "He hates this video." So, why don't
we watch it, chat, before we get into all the
>> Hey guys, please hit like on the video
algorithm. If you want to support more content like this, you
can do so at
If you have cash app, you can donate at dollar sign shimmu41.
Also, channel memberships and super chats are enabled. Techone,
a streamer with close to a million on both YouTube and Twitch,
has spent the past year embroiled in a assault scandal with his
ex-girlfriend. And while facing these serious allegations, it
was discovered that his father, who he had brought on streams
and podcast, was one of the most infamous in US military history.
The absurdity of the situation piqued my interest. And after
putting together a timeline of events and testimony, what I found
was a man willing to lie, deceive, and manipulate around him.
documents I found. I believe this video will offer an exclusive
look into what has really been going on with Techone. And it
is not good.
Well, by the end of the video, you will at least have some clarity
as to how we got here. But you know what they say, like father
like son. >> I don't know what happens, bro. Just bad follows
me like the plague.
>> You take my cash out. >> Yes. And >> why
are you doing that?
>> Because Tactone is the bread winner. He makes the money.
No, it's because you're
>> responsible human being. >> That's like saying
you're going to make but not have the money shot. It ain't there
ain't a money shot. She looks real submissive and looks like
in the words of Holly, I can take a pounding. >> She was
going to do something much worse. So bad it would have ruined
all of our lives. I'm not going to say what it was that she was
doing, but it was so horrific it would have ruined all of our
So to give you guys context of this moment right here, Pink,
>> this is when Pink was dating Teeone. And this was when
Pink was under the illusion that Fe, who was Tee's first girl,
not girlfriend, wife of 10 years,
was a horrible woman who was convict who was who was saying that
Tee was a and Teone was a vile human being. and they settled
out of court
and they have an NDA now.
So, she was under the illusion that Frame was a terrible, terrible
person. >> Pink was lied to years of a wife. >> She
would never make this up. >> Was a terrible, terrible person.
And that's why she's saying in this moment that Frame is a bad
woman. She doesn't understand and doesn't know because Techone
didn't tell her the truth. >> So bad it will ruin all of
our lives. I'm not going to say what it was that >> you're
such a scum.
mean there's all night again. Yes. >> What about being
unkind and treating people as less of being smarter streamers
already? You
>> infinite techone destruction
>> are saying.
>> You're such scum. >> Cuz you're not making any
sense.
>> What about just being unkind and treating people as
less for being small streamers? What
>> that in a way where you're not speaking >> No,
I wasn't. What about just being unkind and treating people as
less?
>> Total te >> I was talking about the girl you're
>> Tatto destruction. Okay,
now hold on. >> The the doctor.
>> Did I tell you guys about that? >> She was doing
>> Okay, bro. Okay, bro.
>> And why are you doing that?
>> Because
techone is the bread. >> Listen, you know what my dad said
to me the other day, chat? >> And he's right. >> You
got crying techie. He said everyone that gets in this kind of
industry for streaming and entertainment,
they all they they
99% of them have a bad side to them, a really bad side of them
that they try to hide. And he's right. He's absolutely what I've
learned as I've gone through this, he's right. Uh and I think
even in a bigger context, chat, streamers have it way worse because
they are idolized and seen as gods while they're there and their
job is to be a degenerate. And when you when you feed them that
kind of stuff, they they think what they're doing is fine. Jolly
Ranch Zoo. Wait, aren't you that one girl?
Damn Oxford study always right. What are you trying to say?
Go ahead.
>> That's That's like some uh white male Asian female [__]
isn't it? >> What do you know about? >> Isn't that
the reference?
>> that's the reference, isn't it? >> Oh, is she
talking [__] about Misk?
>> I thought you were with an Asian. No. The [__]
>> She is talking [__] about miscos.
>> Listen, we don't call them side hoses. We call them
women. Okay, we respect women here. I know that a lot of content
creators and streamers want to make you think that I don't respect
women or my chat doesn't respect. But we are probably one of
the most respectful communities to women in the history of streaming.
Want to know how? We made half the girls that are popular on
Twitch. We have grown them. We are We are one of the nicest community
when it comes to women ever. >> These women would never
have succeeded without me. >> It's true. And I'm not even
just saying that because I'm trying to glaze. It is literally
factual. The girls that hate me will even say that's true. My
chat is one of the nicest when it comes to women and most respectful.
And we've always >> sent her a little bit. >> We've
always sent her >> the money. >> You can't deny it.
It's true. >> Because you're a
>> responsible human being. >> That's like saying
you're going to make not have the money shot. It ain't there
ain't a money shot. She gets real submissive and looks like >> that
was the biggest lie I ever saw in my life. I'm gonna go back
to this. >> You want to know how delusional Tech's chat
is? Chat,
>> his mod is telling Techone that he's
>> There ain't a money show. looks real submissive and
looks like in the words of Holly I. >> So Chad, if you
want to know how gross this man is, he was literally convicted
of so many rap charges in when he was uh when he was in the military
that a law passed for him to tell you how bad of a man Teone's
dad is.
>> Teone claims he didn't know ever that his dad was this
bad boy, that he didn't reach over the line there. >> Very
hard to believe that this guy didn't ever hear about the fact
that his dad's a mass in the military. >> Kind of impossible.
I'm going to be honest with you. Um, that's like someone not
hearing or understanding that Lucari was a or had things on his
computer.
>> mass assaulter mass
that your dad was a rapist. Bully assault charges >> brought
him on because you thought he was okay. I do not believe you.
I'm sorry. I don't think >> she was going to do something
much worse. So bad it would have ruined all of our lives. I'm
not going to say what it was that she was doing, but it was so
>> Couldn't they have kept it from him? Do you really believe
that? Do you really believe that Teone didn't know for 30 years
what his dad had done? Do you do you believe that?
You really think Teone never heard about the fact that his dad
has a law passed against him? >> That's just what happens.
>> Would have ruin >> Let me ask you a question.
>> Wouldn't he be on the defender list? It was being tweeted
at him. Oh, I know. I'm I'm just trying to play devil's advocate,
which is >> No, I think I think as a part of his didn't
get tried in regular court. >> He knew.
>> Wait, no. I think I think it didn't get tried in regular
court, right? got tried in like military court >> and military
court's like a totally different thing. >> It will never
not be the hottest thing ever when a thick female has a in their
>> Am I going to get cancelled over this? No. You want
to know why? Cuz I don't have secrets. >> Techone as a
streamer is best known for playing [laughter] and promoting gotchi
games like Ginchin and Impact, which from what I can tell is
essentially like gambling for children as these sorts of companies
generate revenue from users gambling on polls to get an endless
supply of sought-after characters and >> We get a new fivestar.
We going to get it 100%. You want to know why? Because I'm supposed
to. Cuz I'm supposed to. And you want to know how I know? Because
chat, right now, if you follow my stream and you're new here,
you get three free pulls in Hawkeye Star Rail. That's the crazy
thing. Here we go. We have eight more to go, baby. Two.
HERE WE GO. HERE WE GO. HERE WE GO. PLEASE. PLEASE CL
YOUR W. CLEAR UP ON YOUR W. CL.
PLEASE.
GO. [screaming]
OH. Oh my god.
>> Want to chat if you hated Teone for years? You know,
my my dad said it last night. [laughter] He said that Teone was
the one person he met during Camp Canoot that he hated. Like
it it wasn't even it wasn't even that Tee My dad hated uh
uh like knew anything about him. He said the second he I shook
his hand, I thought he was weird. I And I I'm I'm going to say
this even before all this stuff came out. Um, I think most people
hated TechCo like in
everywhere they hated Tech. It this is I don't understand how
TechOne has a following. I don't get it cuz you want to know
the truth. The The number one reason it's not even the line.
How do you listen to that guy? How do you listen to him yell
and scream for hours? How do you watch a 30-minute video of him
screaming and yelling? It's so >> like a little over the
line. I think Tekum was popular when he was like a nice guy.
>> The way he acts is so >> but he wasn't a nice
guy for very long. He wore out his welcome in a lot of places
very quickly. >> I don't get it. Besides like chuds who
like WWE and want rifles in their house.
>> Latest iteration of Techone sucks. Everybody hates the
latest. >> That makes sense to me though because Kai has
a very young audience and they like yelling and screaming. That
is normal for kids and underage kids like liking that kind of
stuff, right? I understand why Kai has an audience and Kai is
also very entertaining with it. I do not understand why Tech
has an audience in in any capacity. the one most wanted unit.
>> Kidding you. I almost passed out on the ground. I'm
not kidding you. I >> Peach Stars hates him so much.
>> Oh, I have Me and Peach have had very long discussions
of how much we hate
>> Very long discussions Techone. Uh, many people in Austin
hate Tech, by the way. I'm not going to pretend that many people
like Techone. There are very few creators that like Techone.
Very few. Very, very few. Why? Because it wasn't even about the
Pink Chu allegations. We just hated him. was passed out on the
>> He's just annoying. Like that's it. Like it's it's not
even about the allegations. The dude was just annoying. >> How
did this guy get into OTK? Rich
>> and I'll be honest, chat, when he came to OTK, uh he
came to the OTK one year
>> Uh I >> He Char's new co-host. I don't think so.
>> I was I was lovebombed by him and so are a lot of us
and we thought he was good.
>> That's it. We just thought he was good. Um, I I didn't
I didn't expect
uh this to be the reality of who he is. >> Ground. My blood
pressure was so high. I swear on my life. I pinky promise. I
was about to pass out. This feeling freetoplay, Brona. >> Even
Techone, the one promoting these games, doesn't seem to be immune
from spending large sums of money on exploitative Chinese crap.
Ah, yes. My two favorite Chinese imports. Genchin Impact. You're
too nice. is, you know, I'm honestly I don't want to like glaze
myself, but like I am actually so nice to way too many people
that never
the whole time. I had $2.5 to $3 million in my name. Okay. >> I
gave this guy $300,000 cash.
>> To move near me. >> We just get a network. I gave
him $300,000 cash, a guy I hardly knew to move near me because
I wanted to help
Okay. Like that. That's a lot of my money. Um, that was a lot
of my money, but I gave it to him because I I liked him and I
wanted to move near me. I hardly knew him. He wasn't a friend.
I I just wanted to support OTK and support him. So, I was like,
"Dude, look, little bit of conflicting stuff here." Pay me back
cuz he said he was making like 20k a month doing Genchin and
I'm like, "Okay, just pay me back like quick." >> Only
Rich wanted him there, but Msk also gave him a $300,000 loan
to move. >> Stab someone that gives you money like that
or supports you. Like, it's crazy that someone would do that.
Even if you hate my guts, the fact that you're willing to do
that to me blows my mind. Like you're willing to attack me for
years just for because and I gave you that money, man. And it's
not like I ever talked about it really on stream. It's not like
I really like really attacked him publicly. Like I might have
made jokes once in a while, but >> I will say
now you don't get total cart blanch if you give a $300,000 interest
free load to somebody, but you get a lot of leeway, okay? where
it takes a lot for you to go back at that person. >> A
little bit higher.
>> Wait on on just Genshin. >> Yeah, I spent half
a million dollars on Genshin. In fact, >> Tecton joined
OTK or the one true king streaming organization on November 25.
>> I'm going to say this about Te there. I literally don't
believe anything this
>> You know what I didn't check when I sent him this video?
I'm guessing Shimu might not have had the best the best, you
know, opinion on Msk. I hope this isn't a like self- rape video
for Msk, too.
Oh no, I didn't I didn't actually check that. [snorts]
>> Wild that this was our universe, huh boys? Wild that
we were all in a room together smiling. Crazy, right? Crazy.
>> How do you know you're in the good times before they're
gone? Okay. You only know that they're the good times once they're
>> Someone said that Misk's or Misk's life's going to be
in a Netflix documentary and he hopes that one day when he's
older, he's going to be able to see it in the in a retirement
home. Brother, I think it might be quicker than that. I'll be
real with you. I think Netflix should pick up my life very soon
because this is insane. >> Streaming organization on November
21st. >> Look who's in the center. Oh, I know. Look who
was in the funk instead of that >> 2021 with streamers
such as Osmanold, Miz, and later Emiru. Interestingly, OTK has
had several different scandals in the same realm as Tech. One
of the CO-OWNERS WAS ACCUSED OF MISKF. You're about to get
covering up an assault. Techone is also one of the biggest Osman
gold worshippers online because the guy walks on water anytime
he comes up. >> The real >> Dr. Pepper. But yeah,
>> reason why I started being a streamer was because of
Asmin. Asmin has been in here. He was earlier. >> Will
be my favorite streamer. The dude's funny. The guy's charismatic
and he feel
would eventually host the Steak and X podcast with Osmanold and
Emaru. Before we can get to the absurdities of epigenetic, we
need to go back to August of 2022 when Teto and Zen wife Free
left him. You've >> been losing weight. Do I look different
than when I first started camp?
>> Cuz I'm bald. >> Cuz your face
>> abusive relationship. >> Mhm. That's why I'm leaving.
>> Okay. I don't like
I'll add that. We've added
>> He immediately tries to grab a Okay. Uh, wait. Uh, uh,
Bro, that's wild, bro. You know, Techone had it in the back of
his head when you said that to. Like, you don't just say that
when someone punches you and go abusive relationship. Like, he
definitely they had talks about it off stream and he was like,
"Oh god, >> abusive relationship." >> Mhm. That's
why I'm leaving. >> Okay. I don't like this joke anymore.
I don't like this joke.
Frig, I'll give you a hug, >> bro. Look how standoffish
she is. >> It really looks like she does not want him hugging
her. >> OH MY GOD, that's so cringe. Oh my god, you don't.
Ew. Ew. She does. >> How old am I? [laughter] I'm 45.
>> 45 years old. >> She's not saying sorry or anything.
Dude, if I if my girlfriend uh said abuse or I said abusive relationship
and she said that's why I'm leaving, I'd be like, can you say
that's not true? And apologize. I'll be like, "Can you tell the
audience in front of you right now >> that that's not true?"
And she just put her hand in the pocket and then he grabs her
to try to make it seem like everything's okay. >> Dude,
I am the conflict resolution god.
>> Amazing. Amazing stuff. >> And that's the response.
Oh my god.
>> From the body language of Frame, it really looks like
she does not want him hugging her today. I appreciate that. Have
a hug back. The pat on the back feels very fathersonish.
Thank you. >> Earlier, Teto would explain to his stream
that he had been hurting his wife for a very long >> Can
I have a hug back, please? Oh my
>> Time with pretty poor explanations. All while Fream
was packing her things to leave him. >> I want to get this
announcement out of the way uh beforehand. I've heard that I
have been hurting someone. I've been hurting someone uh that
I care a lot >> Sometimes, Chad, caring too much is not
good. It's really not. Uh sometimes you can mean well but still
cause I guess
uh to the people who you care about because we've been together
since we were so young. We formed a very bad
>> for one another. >> Sometimes when Frame isn't
in the house >> don't believe his lies. >> I can't
function as a
>> because it got this year we take him out. Okay. This
is the year we take him down finally once and for all. >> Who
I was and who was and when framed wasn't around me. >> We
have happenings are happening human
>> And during that process I hurt my wife because she was
overworked and y'all know that it's even a meme. It's even a
meme. Me yelling frame
sprinting over here.
So I've been >> Have you talked to Frame? No. The reason
why I'm not going to talk to Frame is one. I'm not going to dig
myself into business of hers that she doesn't want out there.
And number two, uh, Free and Teone went to court and they settled
outside of court for a decent amount of change because what Teone
what Fe had on Teone was so bad that she wanted to get paid for
it. Uh, and she got paid. Now they have an NDA and they can't
talk. Just letting you know. this pathological [__]
disgusting liar did some really bad to uh it was abusive and
Tee doesn't want to talk about it because and wants to pretend
that it's just because he's like I can't be alone or whatever
the he's lying he's lying out of his ass he was he was abusive
in this first relationship and then he gets another with Pinku
right afterwards right afterwards by the way and you'll hear
>> long time >> I stopped seeing >> would be
a real shame if Tekone were under NDA through that same settlement
and couldn't correct any of the details that people are now running
with wouldn't it that would be a real shame That would be such
a shame >> where [laughter] she wouldn't communicate with
me because she was afraid due to her past
>> But what I [snorts] realized was is >> live by
the NDA, die by the NDA. Turns >> that Free is not me.
And just because I'm okay with creating content 24/7 does not
mean that my wife would be okay with
>> I thought you were getting divorced.
Same. [laughter] They would divorce only four months later for
it and Teone would start a relationship with Twitch streamer
and Only Fans model Pink Chu. >> Uh but yeah, Ping is one
of the best people I've ever met. She's she's >> right
after being married for 10 years. >> Teone immediately
gets in a relationship with Pinku. >> Never done anything
wrong. A amazing human being. >> Just in case anybody continue
to question if Teong was abusive. >> I want to give hearts
and chat.
I really do. I have heard her for hours talking about stuff and
talking to me and the fact that I I seriously appreciate this
girl for having the balls to go after techone doing this despite
the fact that the internet wouldn't listen to her because she
has an only fans. The fact that people wouldn't listener would
continue to platform this guy and continue to treat him like
he's a good person. You you actually stood up for yourself, stayed
silent, wait two years, waited for court, and you finally got
the justice you deserve. You deserve everything you got and I'm
proud of her for doing it. She had one lawyer. They had five.
And she won
>> The one v5 clutch. >> What was really going
>> on when clips started to resurface
>> How do I deal with them? >> I love him. >> Let's
be honest. Not even you supported her back then. I don't think
that's true. I think that it's something that I was I might have
said it's a he said, she said, and it's a tough thing for me
to talk about, which is completely fair and true. It's something
that I don't support Tech on, but it's uh which is why he was
also >> we could identify who Tee was. This was the start.
Okay.
>> The lies on this clip are where everything started going
downhill for Techone. He sealed his fate with this clip and his
explanation for it. Okay. >> Don't act like I was hanging
out with the guy. Don't act like I had a podcast with him. Don't
act like I was ever supporting Teone at that time. Uh, I hated
Techone. I wasn't his friend. I thought the guy was weird. Don't
act like I liked him.
Okay, chill. Chill. I'm sorry. Well, then don't say when you're
wrong, buddy. I'm sorry. Like, don't act like I was close to
him. Don't act like after she made those allegations that me
and Teone ever talked again. It I didn't. But a lot of your best
content creators in Austin continue to talk to the guy. >> Don't
touch. >> I'm patient. >> Remember this clip and
how it went uh how it went viral, chat? Remember this >> How
do I deal with him? I love him.
>> Don't touch. >> I'm patient.
>> No, you're not. You're like the most impatient moody
I've ever met. >> Impatient when it comes to you, >> Free.
I carry our marriage and you know that. Free. You know that.
>> I think we have a >> dude. I am the conflict resolution
god. >> Tecton gives the game away in this clip for being
a wholly unlikable tool and
>> you see in Tekk
for him?
>> I saw someone that I liked as a person. I liked and
I thought he could be my friend cuz he was very love bombing
when we first met. He was very cool to hang out with. Uh me and
Emmy would play Mario all the time. It was fun to hang out with
him and I thought he was
branch into another section which was gota games in a new new
area. >> So I and he was an up andcoming streamer. So I
was like I think it's a good thing to bring him on because bring
him on be friends with me. >> But my biggest problem in
my career is I always mix business and pleasure and I [__]
up. When I gave him 300k just want to make it very clear this
was four years ago. This was four years ago. This is before any
allegations ever of Tee and this is when him and Free were hanging
out at my house. >> Teone is somebody who like >> you
could call it love bombing. Teone goes really hard early in relationships
to establish rapport and then he kind of >> pulls away
or whatever, right? He wants you to not be mean to him. He wants
you to judge him favorably early in a relationship and he will
pull all the stops early on. Chud Logic described this when Tee
like when he first heard about Chud, Tone would come in and be
like super nice. Hey man, you want to drop tomato town? You want
to play some uh what? Fortnite together.
>> Yeah, Free worked at OTK doing emotes, but she left
or something and I forgot where she worked. But >> on Don't
worry, Mark Carney. >> Don't worry, Mark Carney. We might
go over that tonight. Okay. We might take a look at humanizing
Teone. Can we humanize Teone? I would unironically say I'm probably
one of the best husbands on planet Earth. >> You're a very
good husband. >> No, no. I wouldn't say very good. I would
say one of the best. >> I'm just saying like you carry
in social aspects. I carry in the back at tech stuff and I feel
like together we make a good team. >> But marriage, dude,
I am the conflict resolution god. >> No, you are. >> There's
the%
you are. >> I I am the greatest shoulder to cry off. I
am the greatest consoler.
>> I'm wait everything. The romantic [__] I
do is crazy. >> Like are you >> I mean I >> There's
a guy named Jay still just restreaming your getting tons of donations
and subs on Twitch. Not sure if you allow this. Um, he did a
piece on you. Listen, dude. Um,
>> I think a lot of people have hated me for things I've
done or they thought I >> I think a lot of people have
had problems with me, but I think a lot of us can all come together
in unison. It's like the We Are the World from like the 1980s
when all the celebrities came together. We can all come in unison
to hate TechTown. Okay, I do not mind that he's watching me at
all and it's totally
>> Go. People are bad and people are >> Tech's on
a different level of I've always hated Teone like >> Oh,
look at look at some loser in the chat. People have always hated
some DG loser over here. >> I stopped liking Teone's not
calling you a great second camp canoe when he just kept claing
Nick and thinking he's a >> Hold on. Actually never did
that. DG lying losers. I didn't do that and I can prove it because
when the when it was the easiest to call Miz when it was the
easiest to call Miz and say some ridiculous say that he was like
a I went the other way and I said you know what that sounds like
he misread the the situation that sounds like I I get it. I understand
how that could happen. He's not that's not insult to me. I think
I can see how that goes the other way and it's on the tape. All
right. It's on the >> Marriages and emotions and understanding
and communication. I would say I do about 90% of that. >> Oh
my god. Yeah, she don't shut up. >> Okay, there we go.
>> Yep. She's I was literally going to say she's stress
picking because she's trying to zone out. You can tell free here
is trying to disassociate because Teone just doesn't shut the
up and [__] on him. >> Majority of marriages.
>> Tecton legit ruined Camp Canoe 2 being a whiny [__]
I 100% I Nick ruined it too. But I'll be honest. >> No,
no, no, no, no. Hold on. If um
if people are wondering if I commented negatively on the other
stuff there, yeah, I commented negatively on the other stuff
there. I thought the other stuff there, shutting the power off,
getting mal reviews, that was not so good. Okay,
but on the actual assault thing, I actually said when there was
no reason for me to. Okay, I actually don't think this is as
bad as it sounds.
>> When this car clip resurfaced online, Tek went to sweep
it up directly. But specifically what I find interesting >> minus
2.5k likes >> we pretty much had to get it. >> Our
marriage was good for eight years but bad for the last two point
where we were both resenting each other. Consent content creating
took a toll on both of our mentals and chains. We us they here.
No, you got served in court and you know it's so bad that you
had an NDA on her and you have an NDA and you can't talk about
it because you don't want to talk about it. So, you gave her
$30,000 because you know that you are such an abusive husband
that you want to make sure no one knows about it. >> To
save our friendship, which worked and was definitely for the
better. You may not realize it yet, but this is just an outright
manipulative lie by Tech. Something I will explain in more depth
shortly. Techone would further present this narrative that everything
was all good on stream. >> Also, you got to understand
like Frame doesn't like when people paint me as a villain, right?
Cuz it kind of just like decredits our entire marriage, right?
Like a couple of bad moments doesn't ruin 10 years. You know
what I mean? I just really want Frame to be able to get out of
the public eye. That's all I >> Sure you do. >> And
please God, nobody clip this. Please. It's just very hard for
me to talk about Frame cuz she was my wife for a very long time.
And I don't like remembering how ugly the end of our marriage
got. My life's going in a great direction. And that's the only
reason why it hurts. And that's the only reason why it's scary.
Am I going to get cancelled over this? No. You want to know why?
Because I don't have secrets. That the last two years
were really rough. It was really rough. Now, the [__]
that I would do with frame, the icky [__] I would
do the frame, that wasn't good, right? I'm probably going to
delete this VOD after this stream, but holy, dude, my friends
can't even react to me without it being a hate thread. It's crazy.
>> After [laughter] a back and forth on Twitter about Frame
being free from Techone occurred, Frame would clarify the situation
with
>> quote, "Since some think this is playful banter, it's
not. We are not on good terms, by the way." >> Yeah, dude.
Techone, I remember when this tweet went [laughter] out. >> After
a back and on Twitter about free,
>> this was a post about my donathon being over. By the
way, Teone said, "Thank you." to try to clarify and she ratios
him and says, "I've been free of you for
being free from techone occurred. Free would clarify the situation.
Quote, "Since some think this is playful banter, it's not. We
are not on good terms, by the way, but this is between me, him,
and our lawyers. Sorry for not wanting to talk about my personal
life online. Some things just shouldn't be used for content."
Discord DMs were sent to Techone in Pink of Frame posting screenshots
of a bra being purchased on Amazon from Techton's account well
prior to his divorce. And then >> Yep. Techone. Just I
want you guys to remember this. Techone would tell his girlfriend
and his wife what to wear and what to do. He would tell them
what to wear and what to do. Remember when Asmin and everyone
attacked me because I would I would say to Emmy that I don't
like the cosplay stuff she does when it's too bay and I don't
like that stuff cuz I didn't. And when I first started dating
her, I made that very clear that I don't like the super batty
stuff where you're out or anything. It makes me feel very uncomfortable
because people just are goooo gaga going over you and as of I
don't want that for my girlfriend but for techone purchasing
bras. I never purchased anything for Emmy. What the I never did
any of this. This is wild. Like he would purchase her stuff in
cosplays to make her wear what he wants. >> wearing it
at a later date. Also still had access to the security cameras
and posted pictures of Pinkchu coming in and out of Tecton's
house. This was on a date where Fe was supposed to be with Teone
for Christmas. Because of these new posts, Teone and his new
girlfriend would strike back at freedom viciously. Before we
get into the nuclear response Pink and Teone made, >> that's
fair if you told her to start a relationship. I told her at the
start of relationship, she knew it for years that I did not like
the way that she would put on cosplays and stuff. Unfortunately,
because it was too revealing and it made me feel very uncomfortable.
I also didn't like she would uh, you know, post a lot of the
cosplay stuff and farm skits by accident because she was doing
stuff. >> Like one of the hottest girls on the planet,
unfortunately for him, okay, unlucky, I hated it. Um, it was
a lot. It was a lot. I >> want to jump ahead and let everyone
wear like pajama pants and a t-shirt
ex-wife that he convinced her and told her to do everything.
>> No, msk. Misk. Listen, that's not even my opinion necessarily.
Tamir is not precisely my type. But like, I'm telling you that
she is >> famous for being hot. >> What's about to
come next? >> That's literally what she stands for. current
girlfriend Pink would post the Discord DMs of Frame and respond
with quote, "This woman is a criminal and has caused me so much
anxiety and distress the last year, I needed to take a break.
She spied on me with cameras, even private moments, and shared
it with my colleagues and friends illegally. Without knowing
her, she spread rumors about me, tried to ruin my career and
friendships
in fear of what she would do because she is completely obsessed
with me and is unhinged." >> So, to give you guys context,
at this moment, Fe was dating Teeone. She or not Frame Frame
uh divorce techone and uh because he was a terrible disgusting
boyfriend. He did disgusting terrible things. It was abuse. Uh
it was allegedly ab abuse. Let's go with that. Um it was really
bad to the point where Tech Tone and Hurst settled outside of
court and now they have an NDA. Um so it was really [__]
bad. Uh it was a very toxic relationship. It was terrible. I
have heard terrible things about it. I was there. Uh, I would
hear things all the time, but I am, this is not my relationship,
and I don't air that thing publicly because not for techone,
but because of Frame. I Frame does probably not want that out
publicly for a reason. Uh, and she just wants him out of his
life. So, I will not be talking about it. Okay? I will not be
sharing what I know about Frame. That's not on me. But, I will
talk about Pink because it is a public thing and is a public
court and she openly talked about it. So, this is when Pink was
doing cosplays and she was a new streamer. She was a kind of
small cosplayer. She wasn't really known that well. Uh this is
about three years ago and she was manipulated by Tech into thinking
that Frame was this horrible disgusting person and Teone's the
good guy and that she was uh you know she was being completely
manipulated. >> Free would respond to Pink with quote have
your lawyers reach out to mine. Text had their info for months.
Pink would then start a live stream attacking Frame and announcing
she had gone to the police to press charges on Frame for revenge.
What you're about to see was all planned. And Teone would actually
raid Pink Stream prior to her starting. >> Tecton's ex-wife
has been stalking and harassing me and Tee for over a year now.
She has not left us alone. She has stalked bank statements, internet
history, was spying on me when I came to visit Techie cuz she
I guess she originally was spying on techie and spread revenge
of footage that is considered revenge to people. >> That's
crazy to have this level of glow up like >> have gone to
the police. >> She's attractive here. whatever. But she
went from like as much as I can. >> I don't know if it's
just the goth makeup like suits her really well. I feel like
she almost looks different, doesn't she? >> About the revenge
and yes, >> I can't say exactly what's going what's different
there, but she looks like I thought she was >> really good.
Maybe it's editing. I have no idea. >> Of me public. >> Yeah,
I'm not sure. >> So, I called her out. That was the first
thing cuz I was scared she was going to start a public narrative.
>> Why is she blaming free when it's Tee? Because she doesn't
know. Because she's being manipulated by Tee. Because Teone is
a very manipulative guy and he's manipulating her
>> doesn't know anything into thinking that Freen is sharing
the the screenshots and pictures of the garage and everything
else. Sharing screenshots and doing all these things and spreading
stuff and and sexually harassing her. He purposely did this.
This was all planned by Tech to have his new girlfriend try to
ruin her >> Against me. She has ruined Tech's
>> Are you starting to notice some things? Pink later said
that there was no revenge. So, who was telling her that there
was? She also tries to run narrative for Teone. She even brings
up the divorce court papers. Is she a little kid or something?
Someone said, "Listen, she didn't know and didn't understand
the situation. This is just for a few months and you're going
to see the reality of when she realizes and what happens. Okay,
this was not long. This is not something that she believed for
a very long time. It changes." >> Which I would presume
came from him. >> The [clears throat] reason why on >> I
will also say this about Pingchu. She's actually
Teone canceled plans with Free [laughter] is because I was a
new friend to Tee. Teone had talked to me about the mental abuse
he went through with her. He confided to me about all the abuse
he was dealing with, the cheating and how hurt he was. And I
told him, I don't feel comfortable meeting her. I don't want
to know this person. I feel very uncomfortable. I don't think
I think you should maybe take a step back and maybe get some
help and think about you know what has happened because I felt
bad like he still had empathy Starbucks even after getting cheated
on even after >> I can't use the Starbucks lady picture
anymore though guys cuz apparently it gets like filtered by YouTube
so >> that somebody else leaked a peek all of a sudden
now is an abuser >> people are going to clip for YouTube
>> let me also just >> it would not be good why did
te do that why do you think te labeled frame as an abuser and
and in and Pingchu and they tried to and he tried to manipulate
her into going public
everything into Pinku's mouth stuff. Why do you think deflection?
I've never met her once in my life. I hope I never have to. Okay,
>> Pink is stupid for believing all that regardless if
they were in a relationship or not. I completely agree. I think
that she manipulated and it it is also on her and she completely
understands that she [__] up. But just keep watching
and I'm telling you, you'll understand. >> Go in front
of the gas. It's scary cuz it's like this scary unknown and I
have to just deal with it. And I'm not going to deal with it.
I'm not going to like sit around and just let somebody try to
destroy my life. She was going to do something much worse, so
bad it would have ruined all of our lives. I'm not going to say
what it was that she was doing, but it was so horrific it would
have ruined all of our lives. >> The reason why TeeOne
went nuclear because his ex-wife Frame was about to make her
alleged and abuse she went through from her husband Tone public.
Tectone has denied this for years that this was even happening
by the way. But what people aren't aware of is that legal documentation
between Pink and F clearly states, quote, "The dispute between
Free and Tone relates to a serious and false allegation against
Tecton. During that call, Techone and Pinku learned that Free
had a Google doc and she was planning to release it to the public.
We'll get into further detail later
that the attacks Pink should go back and look at some of those
names." >> Wait, who are the people she told about >> Was
going to go public with the interview she went through with Teto.
>> I saw tone to get his side of the story in any context
I could. At first, he said he was happy to answer any questions
until he realized how meticulously I had gone through everything.
I asked him what the allegations were that Pink mentioned were
going to ruin all their lives, not letting him know I already
had the court documents proving what they were. And he lied to
me. He said, quote, "No allegations were going to be made against
me. This was between her and another woman." >> Oh my god,
he just lied. He just full on lied. Oh my god, what a loser.
Oh, you justly lied to this dude. Good job, Techone. You fully
lied. That doesn't prove what the kind of person he is. Then
what does? Keep in mind your top content creators on Twitch still
aren't talking about this.
>> Yo, Curb Yosh, thank you very much for the sub on Twitch.
Appreciate it, dude. >> It was so horrific. It would have
ruined all of our stream would respond to all. >> Thank
you very much. I'm well aware of the many lies that continue
to be said about me, my relationships, and my alleged actions
as social media isn't the appropriate form to address legal matters.
I'll just say that neither I nor my attorney has heard from anyone
about actually resolving this matter. I won't be commenting on
this further. Pink would even run cover for how Tee treated his
wife in the car clip from earlier, explaining, "Oh, you don't
understand." Teone realized that day that his wife of 10 years
had been cheating on him. >> Keep bits of mind. >> Come
up in a second. Someone ratting on you. caught her and Cruz huddling
on the couch and realized they were cheat she was cheating on
him with Cruz >> based I would 100% cheat on techone I
would do the same thing I would [laughter] totally do the same
thing I do not blame in the slightest for having to try to figure
out any sort of of of of comfort in her life in cheating on techone
I would
I would do anything I can I would like I can care less that she
cheated on techone I Remember people tried to really use that
against her. Like who I don't give a [__] man.
>> there's some hater energy. >> I don't give a [__]
>> She was trying to get away. And by the way, this guy
who's Tee's close buddy buddy, um he once said in a very famous
quote that if don't ever leave me alone on an island with Emiru,
this is another one of Teton's friends who's been to Emu over
the years. >> These people are sick. >> These people
are >> said, "Don't leave me on an island alone with Emaroo."
And he said it publicly. He was on OTK's progressive show and
he got kicked off because of it.
>> His assistant. >> If you guys want to lick me
the clip, go for it. >> Which is pretty crazy considering
only 5 months later announced that tech cheating on her.
>> Has anyone ever here ever been cheated on? How do you
react to something like that? By the way, like are you is it
weird? Like I know some people are like, "Oh, you you're crash
or something when you learn about that like you got cheated on."
But is it weird that for me like I just like oh my god I don't
have to deal with this piece of [__] anymore. >> Technone
as you will see throughout would lie to his audience in a pre
>> dude. By the way I just got to throw it out. That's
the Oh, this might not work actually. Hold on. I might have to
go >> Me and Pig broke up like mid June. >> Uh do
you all need proof of that? >> That was the craziest angle
ever. >> Are we going to take my word for that? Do we do
we
do it anyway? I feel like it's important just because I don't
want anybody to doubt what I'm saying and I know it's a pretty
serious topic that people really like talking about. Yeah. Once
again I want to make it very clear. No ill will towards it whatsoever
as of right now. I don't really care.
>> Okay, dude. Okay, so you just like you have to prove
this and you have to like go, dude. The signs are there, but
uh
dude, [snorts]
Jesus Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ. >> I mean, it was made public against my
will, but I don't care. Uh but yeah, I have a message that I
sent to Jimmy on June 28th where Pink and I broke up. Wasn't
the dude who said this thing on the island EMPI?
That guy right there said that if you leave me on an island with
Emmy, don't leave me on a island with Emmy. Go find the clip
of that guy and let's find out what he said. Uh cuz I'm pretty
sure that guy said it. Did he not say it, chat? Someone in my
chat will know he if he said it or not. He
>> Uh but yeah, it was good. Uh nothing >> You sure
it wasn't Shina? No. Shina said that he he saw he just met the
girl that he off to and he met me and Emmy on a plane that like
a day before that. >> Techone for real just pulled up DMs
of his mod in him and just had this pre-planned so that people
wouldn't think you >> Yep. Exactly. All good. If I ever
wanted to come over, could I or not? By the way, this isn't his
mod. This is Jimmy here. Always welcome. Pink and I broke up.
Keep it a secret and I'm okay. >> It was cheating. >> Like,
why do you have to bring that up? >> Posting receipts of
the real breakup that was in July. Please stop talking about
me. >> That was EMPI who said the island. No, no, no, no,
no. That guy said something insanely bad about Emmy. Zizzix said
something bad before, too. I'm literally going to have to look
it up now. >> Miz has encyclopedic knowledge of everybody
who's ever talked to Emmy. Okay. Encyclopedic knowledge. >> Where
is it? They both did. Yeah, I know. I don't know why people keep
saying he didn't. I remember I remember him. Like, it's not like
this is hard for me to remember. Dreamman
>> permanently mute
tone.
>> Stop lying. I broke up with you because I suspected
you cheating on me. Stop taking pot shots at me on stream. You
know the next day we got back together. I broke up with you on
July 23rd. Didn't want to be your friend with benefits on July
26th. You wouldn't even let me ride in the car with you and Sophia.
And I was outside the house drunk and alone. I'm not. >> Notice
how he immediately breaks up with Pingchu and then he starts
getting and talking to Sophia 3 days later. >> Do you see
how crazy this terrible dog [__] piece of is? >> He
he blames people for cheating and being a terrible person. Yet
he literally does everything he says. He just he just throws
it on the women because he thinks he can manipulate all of them.
>> Stupid forgot that his next [clears throat] girlfriend
was Sophia.
A lot of bad. >> Pink attached text messages to the tweet
of her breaking up with Tech where she specifically says twice
that she was scared of him >> and then she went after his
wife and there was a whole controversy over that. She basically
had protected him, defended him and he used her constantly. >> I
wasn't I wasn't sure. >> After techone,
he would respond in a classic manipulative manner. quote I still
have a date night yet someone but they make it so hard a he's
lying to protect Pink not because he was cheating and trying
to assert a public narrative to which Pink would respond by saying
he's not lying to protect me he's lying because he doesn't want
Sophia to know we were still together I was told by someone else
he told her the same lie we both know how you treated me and
your ex-wife you had her sign an NDA to keep her quiet about
the abuse and told me to specifically go over the car clip on
stream and lied to me and said it was the day you caught her
cheating but I found out later it was a lie just like your many
lies you used to manipulate me to make you >> This guy
lies a lot. This technical guy lies all the time. >> He
didn't even know Cruz till has shown how he treated both of us.
Our friends saw it. My family saw it and I'm glad I'm out.
>> Did you see all that? Pink tweeted this that e that
techone was abusive not only to Frame and that's why she left
and it was so bad they had to get an NDA. Then she talked about
how she figured out all the lies that went gone on in his life
in just a few months and then she got
Yo, Kirby, thank you very much for the gift that sub on kick
now. Oh my god, he's moved from one platform to the other. Let's
go. >> Women that are small, that are weak and he takes
them in and he takes them in and he tries to manipulate them
to thinking he's a good person and use them whatever he needs.
It's a pawn in his life. That's all they are to him. >> Shown
here >> and a [__] machine, but we'll get to
that later. This >> is how he treated both of us. Our friends
saw it. My family saw it. And I'm glad I'm out. two plane tickets
from June 2022 of Cruz flying to meet who later dated Frame.
This is important because it proves that Frame did not meet Cruz
until well after the car clip of Teone acting like an abusive
towards Free Pro that Tech lied to Pink in his audience about
his behavior being because he cheated on him. He is a liar. Keep
bits of mind. This is >> so just again this pink reiterating
stuff, but Frame hadn't even met the guy that she cheated with
until after this clip. But Teone tells everybody, "No, no, no.
She cheated on me. I just found out about it. That's why I'm
being such >> She didn't meet Cruz till a month later,
but he manipulated her into thinking that it was then." >> Teone
would go live the next day. Of course, not to address anything
specific about him lying or the timeline of events. This is typically
what he does, but to talk in vagaries and try to manipulate his
audience. And then one of
the dark side because they're too dumb to realize how good they
had it with the main group. Uh people people who know what I'm
talking about know what I'm talking if you don't it's fine. It's
all >> the signs were there. It's not that this guy played
Genchin Impact and he's a [__] loser. >> This
guy wore tank tops like this every day and he has no muscle mass.
Like you're not buff and you're not good-looking. Why did we
ever think this guy was like anything in our life
in the world? Like you're not towing near the MMA
anywhere on your body. Why did we ever take this guy for egg?
>> Why can't he build upper body mass? Why can't he build
any upper body mass? >> The person who KEEPS SAYING >> GUYS
ARE TALKING ABOUT IT. Why are YOU [laughter] TALKING ABOUT IT?
I KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT. AND I'M LETTING you guys know for all
you guys who know what I'm talking about, just know that person
>> I used to look up to him. Listen, I'm glad that you
got out. I'm glad that you were understanding that the truth
of this guy and I'm glad you got out. And it sucks because I
have a lot of people that said that I'm I'm I used to watch him
and I used to watch him for me. You know what? I understand that
you're leaving. Maybe you didn't get the full context, but I'm
glad there's a lot of people that are seeing my side of the truth
now and realizing that the people that attack me have crazy secrets
and that's why they attacked me is they're trying to bring me
down to hide their
talking about it till the end of time. Uh so we'll probably be
going over this about 80,000 more times. Uh, and it's going to
be weird as and I'm not going to lie, it's going to keep being
weird as Okay, it's going to keep being weird as it's going to
keep being weird as >> He's poisoning the well here. Almost
as if he knows something else is coming. Oh, it's going to keep
being weird, guys. I can't say the person's name or even talk
about the specific allegations being made. It's just so weird.
>> And it's just going to be over and over and over and
over and over again. Uh,
>> yeah, I used to watch him back in Genshin. He is crap.
Doesn't like the entire Genchin community hate him? Like, didn't
they all hate him anyway?
Right? They all hated him. >> And and and guys, I'm gonna
let you guys know this here. Here's the here's the here's the
plot twist, guys. Here's the plot twist.
>> I've done nothing wrong at all.
>> Oh my god, brother. [gasps] >> Oh my god. You've
done nothing wrong. That's the plot twist.
>> When he when he describes why they outed him or or kicked
him out of the Austin stuff, yeah, he's he's being he's exaggerating.
Okay, we can go over that another time. Focus on
because people twisted that and said, "Oh, so you admitted to
everything." No, I didn't. I admitted that I was a boyfriend.
I admitted that I was controlling on what she was wearing sometimes
because I didn't like the fact that she was constantly putting
out stuff that bothered me when we had a very uh we had serious
talk about the fact that it made me uncomfortable. But it and
they twisted all that to make it seem like those were things
I said and I meant that I uh assaulted her, abused her, and stalked
her when I never admitted to any of that. It it was never I never
admitted to anything. Uh like that was serious. I meanted being
basically a boyfriend when Techone straight up just admitted
that he didn't do anything to anyone ever and that he's never
been to >> a girl that's getting an NDA on him because
it's so bad. >> Yeah. Just he's repeating a lot of stuff.
But Kio, yes. Teone, all of the communities he's ever come from
all hate him. They literally all despise this guy. Okay. He doesn't
have a single community that he can still operate in that he's
ever been in for any amount of
>> Bro, thank you guys for all the follows. We are getting
more follows in in the stream than we are people typing. That's
how much we are like people are waking up and realizing
>> and I think it's also how much techone. I appreciate
all the follows. It's like literally this is insane. It's it's
going off non-stop. I really do appreciate it. I appreciate people
waking up and I appreciate Techone. I think the internet can
come together to hate techone. I really do. Um I think it's a
very fun time. >> Police charges, lies, and smears is now
somehow totally innocent of any wrongdoing whatsoever. >> If
anybody asked, did techie do it?
>> Hey, what did it what did it say? Rape tone. Rape is
a reality becoming public.
Priming his audience telling them, "Hey, if you hear anything
weird about me, don't believe it." >> Yep. I mean these
people THEY'RE JUST >> WHAT A SAD FACT OF reality by the
way that as we as we now hit the point where we can call him
rapetone accurately. It doesn't have to be alleged rape tone
doesn't have to be anything like that. He has now confirmed his
rap tone that he is so close and said >> to migrating to
rope tone that we might not give very much time with rope tone.
Rape tone's awesome but >> rope tone is is coming up fast.
Okay. It's it's >> when all she did was tweet on her alt
account one time. One time she tweet on her alt account. She
didn't publicly attack him like crazy. She didn't publicly go
after him his narrative and try to destroy his life. She tweeted
about him one time and she didn't even say his name. >> Cordial.
But holy,
I am trying so hard to keep it cordial. I am trying so hard not
even to bring up their name,
>> Like I had removed from my >> That of course is
only referencing his soon to be discovered BDSM. live and you're
going to talk about your ex and she has some allegations about
you. I think it's totally fair for you to go live and defend
yourself. I think it's ridiculous to have the idea that you should
not be able to defend yourself if you have nothing to hide. Um
I talk about my court case with Emmy all the time because uh
yeah, I kind of have to. It's my job to defend myself otherwise
I'd just be sitting here playing Viva Piñata to 500 viewers as
everyone thinks that I did terrible things. You have to defend
yourself. But Teone wouldn't defend himself. Tecton would just
call her off. >> In chat refuses to say her name because
he's a saint. It's not because he wants to respond to this in
a totally disingenuous way. >> Oh my god.
>> Jeez. It's insane. >> I might have been banned.
>> The worst thing is I'm trying to protect this person,
but they keep >> I trying to protect this person. >> And
then THIS PERSON KNOWS MY DAD HAS CANCER. Like just off. >> You
guys have to understand he's actually trying to
>> First time I'm going to clap for cancer. Let's get a
W for cancer for get takingone's dad. protect his she's >> Oh
my god, the hater energy is off the >> My reputation for
years. The >> said W cancer. What the [__]
>> That I have in turn protected. >> This is so weird.
>> And kept their darkesting secret. And I've done I've
done I've done such a good job of not saying any of the wrongdoings
this person's done. And I don't plan to unless my hand is forced.
But the problem is I worry about this person so much that if
they become aware of their own actions that they might hurt themselves.
That makes me >> He could prove that he wasn't lying, but
you don't understand. He's actually saving Pink's life for not
doing so because he's so empathetic. He can't see it right now,
but he's actually on a cross dying for all of his ex's sins.
>> Because I'm trying to help somebody that clearly will
not let me help them. I I'm not going to hold back anymore. So
off or I am going to say what I need to say. And I'm going to
say this very clear. Y >> I have never done anything that
is >> Some excellent
>> Oh man.
Currently he's dealing with relationship drama. So why did it
jump to being cancelled? >> I mean Jesus Christ. It's
>> I love you. >> Self victimization.
>> Happy day. Happy day. Let's go. >> Just too much.
>> Notice how she doesn't even talk about it. Notice how
she didn't even say a word that she won. Notice how no one would
know about this. She kept silent. She kept silent.
Notice that she is >> she just said today was a happy day.
>> She's letting she just You want to know why? Because
she knows no one would listen to her because only she knows that
if she says anything it'll make it >> So she just says
today is a happy day and lets the internet figure itself out.
>> Watch man. It's like every day all these >> that
was yesterday. I know what happened yesterday. keep my name out
their mouth and I do them a service of never even mentioning
their name to not exacerbate the issue but I swear to God one
of my closest friends coming out
she doesn't mind that you exposed at all hell no
>> Jesus these people are [laughter] so pathetic I am going
>> you think that she wants techone to not people to not
know the truth
>> I think that's I think you're implying something else
there I think you're applying something else >> and the
blinking there. I get it. >> You swore you would never
do this to me because I even told you when we started this I'm
horrified of another person who I tried to take care of trying
to me again. You >> tell how freaked out he is and this
is prior to any of the
becoming public by Pink. He's directly referring to Free screwing
him over. He knows what's coming. And the crazy thing is it's
so vague that nobody in the public knew any of the accusations
Free made. So he's directly talking to Pink preemptively months
before Pink made any of the allegations public and none of the
people have context of what he's referring to until now. >> Over
and over and over again. >> The people who I help the most
always me over. And you know what's crazy? And you see the people
in my chat and you see him asking who. And guess what? I'm still
not going to say it. >> Can we imply that >> because
at least I have some courtesy. That's my problem is I'm too good
of a guy. One day I'll crash out and I'll just post receipts
of everything. >> Cuz here's the thing, guys. I don't do
He said, she said. >> I want you to remember that Tekken
says he's going to keep receipts of everything. And remember
what I'm going to tell you in an hour. >> I keep RECEIPTS
OF EVERYTHING. >> I WANT you to remember what he said right
here that he keeps receipts. >> And I want you to remember
this in 1 hour. It's important to remember that as this has actually
threatens to leak >> Sorry. It's very important. I think
Ms. GIFs just hinted that the video that Pinky Choose said was
recorded of her. I'm guessing Teone kept that and that was used
against him in court. I'm guessing the the video where she is
actually upset where she says, "Yeah, where this stuff comes
up." That's what that just sounded like to me
turns me on when you cry,
>> That is salt. That is real. >> I won't make a
I won't make an every joke. I won't make an every joke. I promise
I won't make an every joke. I'm not making an every joke. I'm
chill. I'm chill. I'm walking away for a second.
>> And people won't talk about this, >> but they'll
talk about my >> It's just the crying thing. It's just
the crying thing. He's not the same. He's not the same. His allegation
is obviously, as we discussed, way less bad. I'm just It's the
crying thing. Okay. It's just the crying thing. Just a >> You
both suck. No, I'm sorry. I don't. I really don't. I really don't.
Dude, the spam. You guys don't read comfortable doing something
sexual and record you and demand you stop making faces and pretend
you like it. >> Did I ever have accusations like that?
>> Did I ever have anything anything close to that? >> I
think
Put out months ago. >> Could you pretend to be happy about
me recording you right now? >> You threw a temper tantrum.
Boohoo. Yep. I I threw a temper tantrum. I got upset. I slammed
the door a couple times like you like no one else has. And um
what else? Uh,
I threw a temper tantrum. I read the room wrong and uh, I opened
a door at a party and she was there. Sorry. Whoops. >> Yeah,
you don't know if it's consensual, obviously. Felt it was worth
pointing >> And again, if you can delete any thing you
have of me, I would appreciate that. So, in text, she's asking
Tech to delete
throw
trips you into giving and says, "Do your job. You don't pay rent."
I could someone find the clip of Pink or Teone saying that calling
her a [__] machine. Could someone find it? It's a
literal clip out there of Teone saying that she is just a [__]
machine. >> Took you to a water park, so you owe me and
all you can do is sleep upstairs. >> That might be him
reading her. >> Oh no. Yeah, I threw my phone on the bed
and it bounced at her in the eye, which then there's multiple
proven things of any in small streamers chat saying that it was
just a bad mistake and it's a funny story. But then she 2 and
1/2 years later tells people that >> communicating with
him through time and space. Focus up. focus on sex with you just
keeps you around as >> now I'm called an abuser machine
and degrades you. >> Now me personally I'm going to just
keep it 100%. It will never not be the hottest thing ever when
a thick female has a in their mouth. I will never need anything
more than that. It's just like wow bro look at this human vacuum
>> Makes you feel ugly. Don't wear baggy clothes. Straighten
your hair. At least wear eyeliner around the house. Your selfworth
totally crushed. I hate that people warned me. I didn't listen
because I was so manipulated. I hate that I was lied to when
another girl who went through worse is trying to come
By the way, >> wait till you hear the court. Okay. >> Remember
the stream Pink did where >> and I want to see all these
people. >> That's what I'm here for. >> Like this
guy on Twitter. Where was he?
Find me. Where's this guy? Wh
this looks like I was talking to Belffian. We're good. >> She
went totally nuclear on Tech's ex-wife. She was going to do something
much more. >> I have nothing to hide to the point where
I literally just leak my DMs and I can give a >> worse
so bad it would have ruined all >> Let me just make sure
that there's >> Wait, what is he doing?
>> What are you going to leak? Whose DMs is he leaking?
Don't leak my DMs.
>> I have a I'm not going to say what it was that she was
doing, but it was so horrific. It would have >> What's
on your notepad?
>> You will see what's on my notepad today.
all of our lives. >> Was originally going to go public
with allegations of abuse against Techone. This is why TeeOne
had Pink go nuclear on Frame and accuse her of revenge and file
a police report. This would lead to lawsuits involving Frame
and Pink Pink. Many of the claims Teone was making that Pink
would parrot were determined to be false and the case would be
settled after the determination in Free's favor. Now, another
settlement outside of this >> in Free's favor. I want you
to remember that it was in Fra's favor
the case. It was in Fra's favor, which means they found what
he did to be right and they settled outside of court.
>> I think he's talking about between Pink and Frame right
now. >> And I think he's talking about that's how bad it
was. >> Maybe. Although, let's see. NDA >> and she
signed an NDA. I wish she might be misunder I I don't know. She
did. She didn't want to deal with it. Maybe she just wanted the
money to move on because she knew that Teone was just going to
keep harassing her and his his community was. I don't know. But
yes, it was an abusive relationship on Tee and she signed an
NDA, took money and left. >> What happened between Tech
and >> So because of that, Fe uh did that. Tech was still
on the loose to do this to another girl and continued doing this
for the rest of his life. And that's why I'm proud of Pinchu
for standing up for herself. We'll keep going. >> I believe
in Free's favor. >> Didn't you loan this guy money? Yes.
I loaned him $300,000 four years ago when I didn't know the guy.
None of us knew him and he was only around for a month or two
>> to both Free and Tech being placed under NDA. So Free
wasn't ever able to go public with her allegations against
>> During that call, Teone and Pinchu learned that Free
had a Google doc that she was planning to release to the public.
The Google doc claimed that multiple people, Vy, Bay, Cuco, and
Chance, Sodapop, and Morris were aware of the alleged conduct
and that Free was planning to release it until less Tech and
his attorneys acquis.
Damn. So, Chance knew >> Ko and Vbe knew >> that
Frame was abused according to >> Frame. Damn, I didn't
I didn't even know that, honestly. I literally didn't know that.
After hearing these serious and false allegations from Pingchu,
Teone freaked out in disbelief and called Kuo to tell the truth
surrounding the entire
Wait, so Cuo explains that her understanding of the dispute between
Freeman and Teone relates to a serious and false allegation against
Tee. Pingchu reached out to Ko
because Kuko had promised to issue a public apology to Pinchu.
However, Kuo explains that her understanding dispute between
Freeman and Teone relates to a serious and false allegation against
Teone.
>> After hearing about these serious false allegations
from Pingchu, Teone freaked out in disbelief and called Ko to
tell what the truth the entire time. During that call, Teone
and Pingchu learned that Fe had a Google doc that she was planning
to release to the public. The Google doc claims that multiple
people vayo and sodapopin were aware of the alleged conduct and
that frame was planning to release it unless techone and his
attorneys
acquisited to fringe demands. >> Inquisited. You love you
love how we say acquies here. Inquisitive.
>> I love that Misgif has an inquisitive mind. Very
dub miz. Okay.
I will say this chat, that doesn't mean that Sodapop and and
Bay
uh believe Pinkchu
didn't believe F.
>> That just You got to understand something, chat. Why
Sodap Poppin's not going to go public with things and do things
and neither is Vay.
Uh unless F wants it to go public, right? Um like that's the
thing. >> Also, it's like an algation. >> It's not
up to him whether or not it goes public or not. It's up to her.
you need very specific circumstances
public with someone else's allegation against people are aware
of this and unless she gets her money which is what she wanted
that she's going to release she's going to release the Google
doc which she gave him the which he gave her the money so that's
that's not on chance that's not on baby bay that's not on them
that is on that don't don't put that on
but it sounds like defended >> thank you for the 20 months
>> defended teto
she did explain that our understanding of the dispute was between
Freeman and Teone relates to a serious and false allegation against
Tectone.
>> But there will be more evidence shortly that they were
very, very similar to Pinks. Me and her are good. Now, >> now
I will say this. Teone is a very manipulative guy and good at
lying. Maybe he lied and manipulated Ko somehow to the point
where Ko believed him over Frame. I don't really know the story,
>> but I should have listened. When you're in it, you feel
blind to reason. I see some comments that are worried. I just
want to let you all know I am out and have been at my own place
and I'm safe. Don't want to worry anyone. I've been >> Wait,
you didn't ask him to marry you? >> Been taking it one
day at a time since.
>> Also guys, kick.com/misk.
If you're watching my stream, you should be watching his stream,
too. Okay? If you like additional coverage over top of him, then
this is the stream. But if you just want to watch this in general,
go watch it through Miskip's point of view so his viewership
spikes. All right? >> Know about this. I'm just keep it
a bug. This ain't funny. This ain't cute. I can no longer help
someone who is this stupid. I can no longer try to protect someone
that is this stupid, who would betray me this much. And guys,
I'm I'm going to keep this vague. I'm going to keep this vague
uh for a reason. Okay? So, if you're confused, you're going to
stay confused. I know the person who needs to hear this is going
to hear this. And I mean this genuinely. I did everything for
you. I helped you with everything. I fixed everything for you.
I was there for you like nobody else was there for you in your
whole life. Your words are most egotistical. >> The fact
that you're letting these people get into your ear, people, >> the
same people who are talking behind my back illegally, by the
way, >> the people, the same people who placed >> under
an NDA where I cannot talk about them. I know they're talking
to you right now behind the scenes and they're getting you to
believe in bull, letting them get in your head and make you imagine
problems that never happened. >> This is such an insane
explanation. His ex-wife manipulated her to create all of the
things Pink talked about. Does that sound logical? And it's insane
how these things that have happened in your own mind, you are
now coming at me and this just isn't cute. So I am going to leave
it at this. My lawyer is going to be contacting your lawyer,
the same lawyer that I helped you get because you were scared.
I'm noting around. >> He got her lawyer
>> with this. >> Pink was scared of a woman that
she self admittedly had never even met or spoken to. Obviously
everything that she knew was coming from Tech. Let's just look
at a portion of the lawsuit Pink filed against Free and you tell
me. On August 18th, 2022, Teone hosted a live stream where he
went on a real life adventure, visiting several anime shops and
attending an elaborate and expensive sushi dinner. On the same
day, F was extremely jealous of Tech's adventure and was pouting
in her office. Noticing Fe, Kerm suggested they go out on their
own adventure. Kim was excited by the prospect of going on a
date with her crush Kerm and agreed. K decided to impress Kerm
and put on her hottest outfit, a 2002 Eric Impossible look with
turtleneck and cargo pants.
>> Why the is that known, bro? What the is wrong with Teeone?
Bro, that's the only way that they would know that is if if Teeone
told her those exact things. Cuz it's not like Pinkchu was around
back then. The only one that was in the house was Tee. What the
is what the [__] is wrong with? Why would he remember
that? Why would he? >> She also made sure that her hair
makeup idea of her hottest outfit being a turtleneck and cargo
pants because Tekone was larger than Span which was
>> Unprovoked
allegations. >> Spence shouldn't be intimidated by Tecton
because he has a micro.
>> No, Teone.
No. No. >> I'm going to let you know something, chat. Don't
do it to him.
>> There are some signs today that show he has a mic.
I'm letting you know.
I didn't know this was going to be said. You will hear some signs
of him having a tech tone. I have a
>> Okay. Okay. >> Doesn't it make a lot more sense?
>> Micro tone. >> All right. I am. >> Are we
ready for this, guys? >> Keep in mind, this is not someone
saying this behind their back. This is not someone saying something
publicly to piss them off. This is legal documentation that she
is willing to say under oath or at least the lawyer talk of techone
unprovoked free respond should be intimidated by Isn't that >> I
think this is going to come up. I think it's going to jump in
documents.
>> I've never seen this item is cuz no one ever let me
have it cuz I'm an idiot. I let people walk all over me thinking
that people understand and I've realized that people don't really
understand. People listen to all day so they should listen to
another which could be me, right? Like I'm not going to let people
walk all over me like I've done for years. I let Techno talk
[__] about me for years and a half. But I I also
knew that this was coming. I knew that these days were coming
because I was confident in Pinkchu. >> We love We love
Pink Chu. >> I just find it rich that after getting Pink
Pu look like again letting her pursue revenge charges then attempting
to free based on Tech's testimony of events, he takes absolutely
no responsibility for any of this whatsoever. Yep.
>> Keep in mind, like I said, that's not someone going
around whispering that in someone's ear. That is his exwife
saying that he has a
>> on court documents.
And you will hear more on him having a
>> just how culpable that tone was after all the drastic
measures Pink took against Frame that they are now on good >> If
you want to do then let's do this. But I can't sit here and dumb.
Thank you so much, which I thought you were medicated for. I
guess not. Skitso the out repeatedly, repeatedly, repeatedly.
>> My ex-wife and ex-girlfriend are crazy. And he says,
"Skitso out. You will hear more about this and realize what lies
and how he deflects everything he says onto these girls." >> So
enjoy
contacting your misunderstand.
We have a psychic because this is ridiculous. I tried to be cordial.
I tried to be nice. I tried to be happy. Does Msk not know that
Teone's like totally public about having literal
>> Check your check your phone messages. >> I would
love to see what any of these viewers think of Techone. I really
would like Do you really think this guy is all that? Do you really
think he's so cool? Discovered that recently. >> Everybody
that I know, the same people
the hardest fuel for the year total destruction fire. Thank you.
>> Everyone wants to pretend that I'm the bad guy. Let's
go. >> I'm done being the good guy. >> The next day,
Teone would post a response on Twitter as well, giving P two
weeks to apologize and retract her statements or he will pursue
legal alternatives. He also proclaims that he was a victim of
assault as well, which is not a good response to SA allegations.
Be the abuse of rape if I'm >> Huh? You triggered my card.
>> Next day, Kittenetic on Twitter makes this post which
I find pretty interesting. Quote, "It's pretty damning that two
women I was very close to told me the exact same story about
the same man without ever having spoken to one
>> I heard the same thing from Frame
>> I heard the same thing. >> Oh my god. >> And
then I met Pinkchu like last year
and she told me
and it's the same.
It's the same [__]
>> It's the same [__] I know. I same [__]
>> That's crazy chat. Just wait >> to the last detail
going back years before they ever even knew the other woman existed.
The same gaslight. >> It's kind of hard to [__]
my Just saying.
I'm going to pin this. Mods. Pin that comment. [laughter] Just
wait until I bring out what's going on and you will understand
why Tech has a And you're right. It is hard to without a
It is very tough to [__] with a You will see. Oh
boy. >> I'm telling you this story is crazy. >> Being
narcissistic, manipulative,
then hearts this tweet which confirms that it has to do with
her and the other person who's obviously frame who is going to
come out with allegations before something happened and NDAs
were signed. Maybe a payout possibly. Pton would also announce
what he called his
>> God, bro, I feel so bad for the girls online, man. Didn't
you say don't leave me alone on the island with Emmy cuz you
know what's going TO HAPPEN? DID I SAY
DID I SAY THAT?
NO, I might have said that with Emmy. The thing is the Well,
the thing is the thing is
anything I say on stream, who cares? I'm going to be completely
honest,
but why not just apologize for being weird and move on? I wasn't
weird. >> Is a micropen smaller [laughter] than >> I
personally think TK were well aware of his ex-wife's allegations
>> I believe it's under three, possibly under two. contract
was up and he chose to renew. >> Let me explain to you
why >> he tried to say and claim that he left because of
uh because of that. We kicked him out because of the allegations.
We didn't kick him out because his contract is up. He just completely
lied. >> Why I left OTK, why I resigned from OTK. The reason
why I resigned from OTK, why I did not res why it off. Sorry,
I'm very tired. Why I did not renew my
that expired on November 1st, 2024. What is a 5 in? No, that
is a normal size techone. I believe a is like 2 in, bro. It's
small as
>> the original contract was 2 years with an additional
option to extend by an additional year, thusly completing my
three years in OTK. And the reason >> already the LSF threads
have leaked a view on Twitter. There's no way that that's what
they got.
Miskf leaks his DMs part two.
Laui still messaging the Amaru skits and the guy that changed
his name to Bell also Bella Deli. This is what you've got today.
This is crazy. It's just it's it's crazy. Wait, look at this.
Ready? >> Look at the >> This is what I the He's
still messaging the guy, by the way. >> I want to see.
>> He's still messaging the guy. No, I'm
No, I'm not. He's messaging me. >> Look at this.
>> Wait, where? Wait, what? >> All I did was I told
him to send everything you got there and then I just responded
to him. the fact that LSF has obviously botted. I'm not talking
to him. He's sending everything to my lawyer. He was sending
me tons of stuff. He's he sent me like weeks of
>> still. Who cares?
>> oh [__] >> Who gives a that I sent
that is a 4chan guy who's sending me information? Who gives a
>> shot? No shot to the real guy. It's not just about Emmy.
That's the thing. It's like it's an emer dude. This guy is sending
me things about everybody.
Everyone. [laughter] >> Like, he's sending me everything
that 4chan says. >> It's not just about Emmy. >> At
all. And how do they know this guy is a doctor? Msk.
How do you possibly know >> Misk is Belina a doctor. Is
that who you're going to see, Ms. >> 40 likes in 3 minutes,
by the way? 40 likes in three minutes, by the way. Not >> This
will go straight to the top. >> 40 likes in 5 minutes.
Not brigaded, by the way. Not completely botted.
He's going to try to have this massively downloaded too. >> Three
inches. So, as long as uh micro isn't three inches, I'm good,
I guess.
>> look at this. >> Oh, nice try. They're finally
realizing that you're just view you're botting everything. Good
job, LSF. Finally, people are doing it. Good. Good. They're finally
realizing this botted in 5 minutes and had 90 up votes. Thank
you, dude. Things are finally changing for us, chat. It's insane
how brigaded my drama was to LSF. It was brigaded to the clip
of me with Emmy with the cheese. Why the does that have to do
with anything? Me yelling at SA years ago. Why the did that have
to do anything? No, it didn't. None of it had to do with it.
It was up for brigade and [__] to make me look as
bad as possible to ruin my life.
>> It looks worse. >> To ruin my life and to make
you guys sheep mentality thinking I'm a terrible
>> The cheese clip was bad. Look, it was bad and it was
stupid of me to get in there. I was mad because I thought she
was going to clean up and it's my bad and I'm stupid for that
and it was it was dumb as me to do. It was I was in a bad mood.
I was angry at her and it was >> Oh, let us pray. >> Was
it a am I a monster for it? No, I'm not. I'm It's It's something
that you can say I'm sorry for and that's about it. Like, holy
crap. It's cheese from 2 years ago. >> Piece of [__]
Let's go. >> Admitting again. I'm I'm willing to admit
what I did wrong, >> but that's not that's not abuse, bro.
You think me saying and and holding the cheese up and saying
that it's abuse?
Cinn was absolutely farming. Yes, it was me when I yelled at
her. It was absolutely farming. Bro, there was a clip of me with
Jason the wing when I walked out of the room
and people were like, "Went, dude. I was farming the chat.
I was farming the chat like I always do." Anyway, microphone.
>> Yo, how old is Chompy? Yo, >> five, bro. Five.
>> Why I chose to not renew with OTK is because it gave
me a weakness. And I realize I really don't like having >> Yeah,
sure. It was just a cosmic coincidence. It happened directly
after Pink's allegations became public. Screw it. I'll count
this one. >> Are you calling me a liar? >> That's
a lie. >> Throne of lies. >> Pressure wouldn't mount
until Teone decided to go live on the 24th and make the single
worst response to allegations. I have >> Hold on. I'm doing
stuff in the
>> wait. Did Msk say to for realations now goes specifically
to Lukari? I don't think anyone can and will have a worse response
to allegations than Lucari did. I just don't think it'll ever
happen again. That 5 hours is so wild. I still can't believe
that was a reality.
>> We're going to talk about everything. However, in regards
to a specific situation, I am only going to give you the tip
of the iceberg
>> because the rest I am going to hold until I need >> I
personally don't want to body shame that much, but microphone
is funny. >> Talk about maybe a little bit more than
actually provide receipts or talk about the situation. >> No,
it's just a classic deflection of I'm just going to wait till
the lawyers talk uh for these guys. If they have nothing to hide.
>> Micro tip of the iceberg. >> If they have nothing
to hide and they have their big audiences to go back on, why
don't you just talk about it and show the receipts? Oh, it's
cuz we're just going to wait till the lawyers talk. Yeah, cuz
you're just trying to wait and stall out you possibly can for
anyone to care about the story. That's why you wait. That's why
you do that. >> More in depth. Considering your last two
girlfriends appear to be calling you a >> I want to let
you guys know one thing. I am not going to tell you a single
lie this entire stream. But at least I'm going to I'm going to
try not to. And you know what's crazy? Oh, guys, in case you
don't know what the allegations are, let's just get them out
of the way. I have been accused by my ex-girlfriend of being
>> right there. I would just walk out of that room and
be like, >> "Well, thanks, Jackie. >> What do you
mean you're not going to try to give your best to lie?" What?
>> Being abusive? >> I'm not going to lie to you
at the very least mentally abusive and potential. >> I've
been accused of all those things. And before there's a guy in
chat who's saying again, this isn't an again thing. This is a
one-time thing. >> It's not literally right right there
proves that in court it was multiple women accused you. >> This
Shimu video is so good. >> Pretty bad
assult and abuse for me. Not just a one time thing for you again.
>> That's a lie.
>> He's a liar. In my 30 years of being alive on this earth,
there are two things that I've never done. I have never cheated.
I have never placed anyone under an NDA. >> He unfortunately
forgets to include the in the list of things he's never done.
>> I'm going to give you guys 5% of the >> I'm not
going to tell you any lies, guys. have in my favor. He doesn't
>> absolutely you and keeps you around as a blood machine
and degrades you. First of all, I've never degraded you. I never
have, never will. And the other reason is is pink. You understand
why I would not have with you as a victim of >> That's
a lie. >> That's not why
>> Why do you think he couldn't have chat? I had trauma
when it came to having sex. This is a known fact. I have told
you this from day one. I've also said if you can't handle it,
that's what it is. I don't want to apologize for being
>> So, this isn't a big secret, but a context you should
probably have is that this was the case for the majority of the
10 years with F and two with Pink, which corroborates Pink's
allegations, the type of relationship that was had. Tectone attempts
to offer this as an explanation, but it really just illustrates
how disordered he is. >> Now, I would like everybody to
know over the course of the past four months. >> From the
front, he can't do that. Then the fact that she's an adult woman
comes into play, okay, stares him directly in the face.
>> Can't do that, man. Can't do it. Can't do it. >> A
liar. >> A liar. >> So, I would say talking about
things is good. He addresses Pink's post and provides only a
single receipt, which in his mind is going to clear the entire
debacle up. Must be pretty damning. Let's take a look. >> Guilt
trips you into giving. >> We call
you do your job. You don't pay rent. I took you to a water park,
so you owe me. Pink, you imply that I was paying to suck my That
is not true. You know that's not true. What you would do is you
would go upstairs, you would record your Only Fans, and then
you would beg me to suck my dick. You say that I would say do
your job, you don't pay rent. This is factually untrue. >> He
says only fans because he wants people to degrade her. >> Here
is you paying rent. Not one time, but multiple times.
That is you paying rent. And now what you might be >> now
you know that wasn't Rent >> thinking is Oh well maybe
those are just taking screenshots. Well then if you're not happy
>> see what I've been sitting on for a long time chat
>> wait was it was allow me to show you your own my trauma
with Tone. I HAVE BEEN TECHONE'S ROOMMATE for a year now wouldn't
be going and say he is one of the most understanding kind I have
ever met and contrary to popular belief
I do pay rent
>> total techone victory did it paid rent she was lying
right only there's one big tech dope issue >> she never
said that she never paid rent she said that techone told her
that since you don't pay rent, you have to pay me back in these
other ways. >> And then we literally saw a video of him
doing exactly that. >> That's [__] [__]
>> She never said that she never paid rent. >> She
said that he said she never paid >> Um is that the garbage
the garbage has not been taken out uh in this chat realize responsibility.
The reality is that she's in my house role playing Goth Hooters
order orderer waitress and >> we got to rebuild the reality.
The reality is she doesn't pay rent. >> This techn guy
can't keep things straight, man. >> Guy can't keep things
straight at all. >> She's not doing her responsibilities
and she needs to do her. >> Oh, I >> wonder what
those uh Venmo numbers were for. I wonder what that money was
for, chat. Interesting. >> Garbage is
dude, he is that is very deceptive on his part. >> It actually
beggars belief. The only >> Liz went from LF to mastermind
KF. Keep in mind chat, I have a date tonight with a doctor. >> Techone
makes to address and fight against these accusations. He just
straight up lies about as he clearly >> "I'm here streaming
the whole night. Did you not rub it in?" >> This was one
of the things I actually asked Teone about. And surprise, surprise,
he refused to answer. >> He's lying. >> I knew you
were lying. >> And I wish she would understand. If she
would just delete the post and apologize, all of this would go
away and things would go back to normal. It's funny how Tekum
says delete posts when Tekon's going to have to delete a lot
of things of this weekend. >> Will you tweet out the proof?
I I will at a certain point. He never does. >> I will at
a certain point.
>> I really truly hope that you guys believe everything
that is that I said. >> Wait, hold on. You're getting a
doctor. When were you going to tell us? >> We'll provide
proof later. [laughter]
>> Wait till you see his proof in in court chat. That's
hilarious, [laughter]
>> right? So, obviously without proof, nobody knows what
actually happened. But it's like, dude, this guy's only receipt
was him being totally deceptive and just straight up lying, caught
in 4K. And here's the thing, it's not even on him to provide
proof. But he said he had it and will provide it and just never
does as things get increasingly worse. >> Instead, what
he does is he tweets about Hassan shocking his dog for two and
a half months straight.
>> I believe Shimu asks him for that. Suspicious. Literally
him never talking about the response would have been better.
Worst response ever.
>> Is a miserable place.
>> And I know that
now that I have shown proof with receipts that I am cleared of
all wrongdoing.
>> Oh my god, bro. He didn't even show anything. He showed
nothing besides the fact that he's like, "Bro, it's crazy."
In January of 2025, Pink would state that Fream never actually
had revenge for her. She was lied to and used as a pawn to defame
someone that didn't deserve the hate, that her and Free had cleared
up what really happened and that any lawsuit/charges
wouldn't be pursued, and that most of what was put out was distorted
in order to defame Tech's ex-wife, Freen. On January 15, made
an announcement basically saying, "Hey guys, I know I said I
was going to sue Pink, but unfortunately, she knows all the loopholes
and defamation cases. Yes, the Young Only sounds like this. I'm
not >> keeping track of this as well, guys.
>> what if my coochie comes out?
>> Well, then here's a
my sisters are now gamer nerds and weebs and I have infected
them >> is a defamation savant totally ruining your life.
This makes total sense. Don't question it. But from the website,
subhuman degenerate just $3.
So people are calling this guy tiny. >> Some people are
just growers man
or her by name. can be actionable on grounds of defamation if
a reasonable person would understand the communication as referring
to the >> Thank you for the three though as every single
person on the internet that knows about this understands that
it's being communicated by you. It looks like you're full of
yet again >> been lying to me. I'm going to charge you
with perjury. >> He also states once again in the face
that it's actually him that was assaulted and that Pink is actually
inhumanely weaponizing assault against the real victim, Teone.
Again, it's just a terrible response regardless of its >> I
abuse women and assault them. One has an NDA on me and made me
pay $30,000. Uh the other one is that coming after me. I married
one. The other one I dated right after the other one. Um I basically
for the past 10 years of my life been a terrible disgusting human
being and vile. My dad is known as the ultimate with the exodia
card of rape allegations. And um you know I'm just going to say
that I've been insulted so therefore it's fine. >> When
facing >> I also have a micro and I only can uh I I want
a [__] machine and I won't pleasure my girlfriend.
Why >> these accusations? >> He also brings up the
NDA but sort of lies about ever putting anyone under the box.
Wouldn't have believed it actually for a fact going to come out
with allegations against
>> I would like to make this very clear. I agree. I think
broken families really with these people makes them into like
techone. I don't have a broken family whatsoever. I never did.
A lot of my people around me have broken families. Half the only
parents I go I hang out with, they don't have dads. But I will
say this, my family, try hard sevens in the chat. >> After
that, settlement payout or something happened and both parties
were put under NDA. 2 weeks later on January 23 witness contacted
the police and reported tech. A couple of months after the pink
allegations became public, Tone got a literal Berserk tattoo
to represent his struggle. If you don't know about Berserk, essentially
the main characters get what is called a brand of sacrifice where
after receiving it, they are doomed for eternity to be pursued
and sacrificed by demons. This guy gets accused of abuse and
is acting like he is guts from Berserk. Literally,
so cringe, dude. So insanely cringe. Yes. Yes. Look at this guy
and laugh. He literally tattooed his own humiliation.
Okay. He tattooed it on his chest. accused of abuse
>> and that's the level the persecution complex goes to.
Okay. >> From one ex and the other ex was abuse and assault.
>> Very sad. >> And he does
>> this like >> micro gut now. >> Micro gut
>> branding himself to represent his struggle. It's unbelievable.
He's like guts guys but instead of fighting demons he women not
>> but he and he has no muscle mass at all. Like I just
stop wearing. Look at he's trying to like flex his traps. Bro,
>> this but what do you think Berserk is famously controversial
for? You guessed it. Gratuitous amounts of essay. I'm not kidding.
This guy got anime tattoo after getting accused of it. After
he cut off communication with me for the next few days, he started
email posting stuff like this as well, which is hilarious. He's
guts. For real. For real. After being sacrificed, I guess I'll
be bored.
>> So such a cringe dude, man. He's so >> And that
should bring us to the present. He acts like a cringe emo kid
in like middle school that gets bullied and he's 31 years old.
>> And unless you've been living under a rock for the past
6 months, you've probably seen an entire legion of content creators
crying about this guy. >> PAKISTAN BIKER. >> YES.
Somehow the man with the small head who kicks a bag worse than
any mid-40s woman doing jazz or size has become the face of radical
politics and terrorism on the internet. So much so that the feds,
we love that clip. That Twitch fans. For those of you who don't
know, I was uh I was detained by uh Customs and Border Patrol.
I was tactically ascertained. They're watching. Oh, the feds
are watching. They're always watching. Feds are always like this.
Okay, now we know for real. People are so obsessed with taking
this guy down. They've actually weaponized the ADL to go after
him. >> But all of us need to call it out. I'm thinking
about the New York Times doing a gauzy profile a few weeks ago
of this gamer Hassan [__] Like extremists should
not be empowered. People who spouts he's in danger of this. Okay.
Don't take a side. Mis
of Sam putting on an Irish accent talking about hunting him down
in his house in California. We've now entered a period where
every single day is filled with people clutching pearls and about
how the small head man needs to be banned. The chibi. >> How
did Chibi Reviews possibly tweet that the thing about tech is
not that bad when this video existed? I didn't even know this
video existed. How did you possibly tweet that Tech's not that
bad or like that you're going to wait and see the core case stuff
when this video is so bad already? >> Platform because
he's a dangerous man. >> Are you kidding me? I didn't even
know this video exist. >> Since working at the Young Turks,
this isn't really a new development. But if I >> He deleted
it now. Shut up. >> Wait, he deleted the second one? Dude,
Msk did Misk just chippy reviews. >> No, somehow I feel
like he didn't delete the second one. I feel like the guy probably
knows that he did the first one and then
>> you fat fingered your SP your phone when you were earlier.
I fat fingered my phone and accidentally deleted this tweet while
walking my dog in the silica. I'm supposed to get to reinforce
my statement. There's people trying to use it as [__]
I find it hilarious. Yeah, because this is complete bull. This
dude likes to spread lies. Huh?
>> Where's the chronic tweeter? >> You put three
dots $3.
Someone explain how TeeOne ended up more dead than the Minnesota
ICE victim too soon.
>> Uh, yeah, too soon. But >> why did Weinstein ogre
Tech decided he wanted to get in on the Hassan bad craze by announcing
he was leaving Twitch? I am genuinely considering full swapping
to YouTube if this terrorist propaganda isn't punished harshly
and immediately on Twitch. Yep, >> my fathers, my brothers,
and our >> Why did he go this route? He knows because these
communities are so die hard that even Teone being a ter terrible
person he is, some of them might stick around even after it because
he knows that they're that stupid. >> Soldiers did not
bleed, sacrifice, and die for this to be allowed and promoted
on Twitch. This needs to be changed immediately.
I did not watch my buddies die face down in the muck. The song
would respond basically to people with what happens next elevates
the story to an alltime. Apparently, Teone, as soon as he came
after me and talked about his father's like military record or
>> this was so funny. The internet
found out that >> that dad did the same that he did.
>> And victims like Heath Phillips when he told his commander
his report was ignored. The Department of Defense says 19,000
incidents of assault occurred in 2010 alone. Nearly 90% went
unreported. The biggest photo you see is of Colonel Michael Robertson.
He was convicted of 14 counts of assault. 14 >> doesn't
fall far from the tree, folks. >> Hey, you know they got
your man. They got your man on charges. >> Yeah. You be
hanging with [laughter] you be hanging with >> it works
for the father and the son. >> He was your bully.
>> For the father and the son. >> Being embroiled
in abuse and allegations for months. He's own father turned out
to be possibly the most infamous sex fest in US military. >> Not
funny. I don't know what his dad has anything to do with it.
involving his parents is Are you kidding me? What do you mean
involving his father? His father's a disgusting human that should
die. Like he's an a disgusting gross
vile human that deserves to die. >> What this about? Whoa.
Holy [__] >> He I'm not sorry. He deserves
>> This is actually terrible.
>> The reason why people are bringing it up >> on
his own. Uh, no. It's because Techone constantly was attacking
Hassan, saying that Assan is a hard [__] >> Yet
his dad was the biggest ever and brought him around people and
everything >> See Matt NLT over in his chat friends and
hung out with him all the time and talked to him all the time.
>> He made his dad part of the content knowing his history
congress hearings in an attempt to stop
on that. Techone father >> Teone would talk about and go
on and on about when Hassan went to the brothel.
>> What was it? Underage kids or something. >> He
would lie about it. He would lie about it. >> Like that's
the big thing people tried to say that he went to a a brothel
in in in Amsterdam.
Yes. Sorry. I was wrong. >> Future assaults by using him
as the example. I rise again today to draw attention to the epidemic
in our military of
>> the brothel was rated for tax evasion but they've twisted
it to be like for minors. I know >> assault 19,000 women
and men each year are or assaulted in the military. This travesty
is not being addressed and I will continue to speak out on this
floor until it does. >> What does this what does this poke?
>> I'd like to tell the story of one of the 8% that were
prosecuted. The story of Colonel Michael Robertson who commanded
Fort Bliss's 31st Combat Support
>> When did this all happen? Does anyone remember what
time this happened when Hassan got or this all happened?
>> Peton's father is Colonel Michael Robertson, a former
US military officer who's convicted of 14 charges, including
harassing through and assaulting five >> No, no, no. I
I mean
when it came out Dwire was a military airfield
river valley in Afghanistan
last week. Colonel Robertson was convicted by a military September
of 14 charges including having on his government computer
harassing three women and assaulting five women. Eight women
that served under his command testified at great cost to their
careers. Good to edit up.
>> Robertson routinely touched them without permission
on their thighs and buttocks and encouraged them to look at computer.
Some testified the >> You want to know how I don't believe
Teone didn't know this about his father?
>> Cuz Pinky said so. Cuz Pinky literally tweeted that.
Cuz Pinky literally said that he was lying. And if we're going
to trust one person out of the two of them, trust Pinky. my dad
comes up
and I'm I wonder
>> I I'm probably
going to say
that Teto's dad would come up especially if this was >> Harassment
occurred daily despite repeated warnings. Colonel >> it
was on TV. Kids would bully the [__] out of him all
his life. I wonder I I I I don't know for sure, but I I would
probably assume he knew, but I I wonder how would you not know?
Robertson also emailed
friends and female subordinates. What makes the defense's answer
to all these actions that all of these jokes and the touching
were attempts to boost morale? Colonel Robertson. The majority
of asalants are older and of higher rank than their victims.
They abuse not only their authority but also the trust of those
they are responsible for protecting. Survivors could email me
at
gov if they would like to speak out. >> This was all part
of the creation of the Assault Training Oversight and Prevention
Act, which was created because of Tech. >> They passed
legislation to stop TTO's father. Okay. >> Get any more
absurd than this, right? Well, you would be wrong as Tecton regularly
would have his father on live streams and podcasts. And what
do you think that typically looked like? >> Obviously,
you're not aware of my first podcast with Techie. I showed you.
What do you think about that? >> Do it again.
>> The daddy issues. >> They all have daddy issues.
Well, she has a facial expression as if to say, "Hey, sailor.
I like the little short dress. She looks like she works out."
>> One of the first things Teto says to me, he's like,
"Sup, dude. By the way, my 17-year-old father thinks you're hot."
And I was like,
>> First thing he did was he put me into some kind of headset
and costume and put me in this AI room. VR chat. >> Am
I moving for Oh my god. >> Yeah. So that's that's Kale
and that's >> Yeah. But how Oh Lord have mercy. And so
he's got me in that headset and I'm in there and it's getting
bad >> and but I don't know if they're if it's as dressed
up as a girl.
>> I got you. >> Right. Cuz that's the thing. >> Yeah.
Or whether it's you dressed up as a girl. >> Probably mostly
Asmin.
>> We're going to give him a heart attack. I swear to God
convicted her father. >> What the [__] [laughter]
kind of comment is that? >> May or may not be men is insane
even by my standards. >> What kind of comment is that?
>> Oh god, we're slowly shifting the snark to Teto's dad
over Teto. Oh no.
>> Oh, what the [__] Okay. All right. >> What kind
of comment is that, bro? >> Oh, I'm looking for this this
pink tweet. I'm looking for the uh the tweet where she like outs.
Okay,
I'm trying to find it. Where is it? I'm trying to find it cuz
I I'm looking for the tweet where she talks about Emirou cuz
she definitely talks about some tweet here. This is how you get
the negative negative temps mean negative in for microone.
>> Negative temps mean negative inches for micro tone.
I don't know. That's I'm pretty wordy though. I'm not very I'm
not very tur man. Can you actually quote tweet him? Oh, it's
a picture. He's He's going to get so self-conscious, dude. >> Open
the tweet. >> Huge micro tone tweet. What is this? Yeah,
we already pulled it up. We already pulled it up.
Okay, hold on.
>> I need you guys to juice this tweet. Okay, juice this
tweet right here. Juice this tweet right here. Juice this tweet
right here with the elephant. >> Father threw me to the
ground. >> Juice that tweet. Juice that tweet.
>> It's incredible how his dad accused him of all this
stuff and he's trying to make it seem like that too. Twitchers.
the problem that it's so sorry for him when you know what you
should be saying techone in this current moment if you actually
cared my dad all these people that ruined that said this uh >> I'm
not giving you the choose to tweet this there >> my dad
feel sorry for the victims that are going through all this stuff
and had to deal with my dad I will never talk to him again >> and
he said give me a good reason not to shoot you >> so you
felt comfortable bringing your father around [laughter] all of
these public people several times now pay attention to that >> yo
J are you still watching me can one of crazy in chat. Try to
find um uh Tecton's dad's >> uh where he why he went to
jail and see if that he went to jail for anything besides that
because I just want to give Tekone the benefit of the doubt that
he didn't know because maybe he went to jail for a lot of things
and one of them was
his content. So we could he knew his dad went to jail. He said
the reason why he knew is because or said it is because his dad
went to told him he went to jail for touching an arm.
Tech tone. This is 2011. You were like 16 years old at the time,
17. You're not that stupid. You're not 5 years old and going
to listen to your dad. You knew what was going on. You probably
went to the court. Am I going to pretend that you didn't go to
the court? That you didn't listen to the hearing? That you didn't
hear what's going on? That it wasn't on television? Are you kidding
me? W viewbots, brother. There is no way. There is no way.
All right, bro. >> I don't think he's out of these viewbotting.
also got the name totally wrong. [__] man. >> Chat,
type yo.
>> Let's see. Go ahead.
>> I'm just, by the way, I'm literally just asking Shimu
because Shimu is the actual, you know. >> You think this
is
>> Do you see the chat? Do you really think this is debotted?
>> I'm just tell them what the giveaway was. I just said
type.
>> Do you do you really think this is
You still want to come out here and say
>> it's not viewboded, baby. You know what's happening
right now? People are realizing that the people that have attacked
me, that the people that accused me of terrible and disgusting
things have such disgusting, dirty secrets in their own closet,
that they deflected it and did it on me. You want to know why?
Because that's what they do. You got to type in chat, guys. They
throw it on everyone around them.
Because they have such dirty, disgusting secrets. I am not one
of I did not deserve this at all. I have never deserved to be
cancelled. I didn't deserve the first one. When people accuse
me of covering up salt, which by the way, if that happened in
2026, literally no one would give a not one person would care
about and say that's a big deal. They'd be like, "Yeah, Slick's
bad and miss whatever." They wouldn't even care to try to put
me into it. But back then, people cared because everyone ganged
up on me. It's a And I stayed silent for my org. I did it. I'm
not doing it this time with Techone, and I'm not I didn't want
to do it with anyone else. I'm done. I'm going to tell the truth
of these people, everyone that I used to hang out with, and show
the realities of what these people are. Why? Because they're
terrible people and disgusting. This is vile, by the way. Like,
I'm not even going to pretend a decent guy or or not even remotely,
okay? He's a vile human being. He abused and assaulted both of
his girlfriends, his wife, for years to the point where she got
an NDA on him.
Then his second girlfriend comes out and says that he would grab
her and force her to suck his
and no one cared and they still talk to him. They would still
pull up his YouTube videos and say he's a good guy and they were
trying to be friends with the guy. >> I hate how long you're
going to out him as this abusive monster. It's strictly in my
opinion to garner sympathy from his audience and just totally
using his father to do so. >> Now obviously this isn't
really anything that I just >> Oh, I wonder why Uffy would
possibly ever defend techone. Oh, look, it doesn't exist.
>> Really want to talk about on stream. However, um a really
>> I was just want to say I'm sorry I was wrong about you.
It's totally okay, dude. I get the internet and I understand
that people hear things about me and they just run with it because
why? It's the internet, dude. Like, I get it. It is the internet
and you guys might not read things and you might see, you know,
you see things, you're like, "Oh, I believe it." You see some,
you know, line on Twitter and you just read the headline. Um,
you know, I get it. I I totally understand. I never understood
didn't understand why viewers put it in the chat one more time
because I get it.
They're easily impressionable, but if you do your research and
due diligence, you can even listen to Emu's stream and read it
back now and listen to what she said. It's ridiculous that I'm
in this position. It's ridiculous. Thank you. Let's [__]
go. >> And then you hear guys like Techone who had two
women attacking him for abuse and for assault. Two women that
not only had these things, they weren't publicly going after
him years later. They went after him immediately and left him.
When you know what my ex-girlfriend did? She literally sat me
down with a note and said, "I want to marry you." I said, "No,
and I left." These women both left >> Hold on. >> Both
left him.
>> Meanwhile, my ex wanted to marry me. So, I left the
country to go to Japan to get away cuz I didn't want to get back
together with her again. I wanted it to be over. >> Great
Twitch streamer. >> You know that has time. >> If
that's true, that's nuts and insanity. I swear to God on Chompy.
I swear to God on everything that's real. It's 100% true. >> It's
100%. >> It could be true, >> but man, it's Emmy.
>> 100% true.
>> I don't know. >> I literally I literally left
the country a week later after I broke up with her when she wanted
to marry me because I said I wanted to go. I didn't want to do
this anymore and I wanted to be done.
>> If I put that there, >> yeah, I'm the problem.
Then 10 months later, doesn't ever file a restraining order.
Doesn't ever file anything to the court. She didn't even file
anything to the court after she went public. Not a >> I'm
not putting that on there.
>> If he looks here, I did DM him. >> Making me
trauma because all >> and I sent messages in chat. >> I
hated my father. >> One of his guys got to see it. Okay.
One of his guys told me that he was proud of me. He always made
me feel like a >> I'm sorry. I get it. Listen, I'm not
going to call him a liar, but just the idea that >> someone's
just totally out on the Emmy room. If he was such an abusive
guy and such a piece of and he was terrible to you and did all
these things and held a gun to your head, why the [__]
would you bring him around your friends? You [__]
Why would you bring him around Emiru and Asminold? You
lying sack of
If I ever knew my dad was abusive, I wouldn't be hanging out
with Emiru and Asmin. Especially when afterwards you said he
thought she was hot. You loser.
>> I never did. It is quite literally the first and third
results on Google when googling your father. >> JSM just
leave just messaged you about the court stuff. >> Name
techone. The third in all caps assault in the military. >> I
just messaged this guy 15 years after the fact is uh it's quite
painful.
>> How what did he how did he go from J Strick to JSM?
The is this guy doing? >> Anyways, fast forward a little
bit. After I was homeless for a tad, I would DM them about how
sometimes I had no money to where I couldn't even afford to eat
and it got met with laughter. >> By the way, guys, you're
>> due to >> enjoying the content. discord.gg/d.
Get in the community. Okay,
>> Let's blame Hassan. Oh my god. Wait till I tell you
what's going on in court. You're going to love it. By the way,
>> to what my father was convicted for, which really hurts
to say. >> I mean, I'm not sure why you've known about
it for the last 15 years. >> Oh, you want to see musical?
Sure. >> It's kind of hard to think of your
as a monster, but [clears throat]
>> appropriate reactions. >> Appropriate reaction.
>> I honestly didn't want to >> shut up 911. I see
you. >> Sure. It's not like people have been posting at
you that you're dead. >> Oh my god. Lau.
Lau. Bro, DUDE, THIS GUY'S VIDEO IS so >> Believe it. Last
night, >> let's go.
>> Your dad's a convicted horrid.
56 likes in January 15th, brother. You knew. You knew. Dude,
I my I know. Like you you knew it got 16. It had 56 likes, bro.
It's not like people aren't tweeting this at you constantly.
You knew Teone >> will have been posting at you that >> dude.
Don't let this lead you to a straight of the fact that Techone's
dad was convicted of harassing three women and insulting five
others. These eight women also served under his command during
his military service. Wow. I am not reading this. I'm going to
pull an asmin. I'm not going to read it. >> Dad [clears throat]
went to jail for being a pest for the last 5 months. And I don't
really know what to think, but I think the fact that Hassan wants
to imply that I'm a monster, >> YOU KNOW THAT HASSAN PER
>> BASED off of who my father is is
>> Like this man has I guess epigenetic memories of it's
just like it's a familial obligation over here. >> And
to imply that I'm a >> Yeah, whatever. or he made a joke
at your expense cuz you've been involved in essay allegations
the past year and then the internet find out that your dad was
one of the most infamous pests in US military history. I get
it. I made a whole documentary about it. It's like an absurd
cosmic joke at your expense. >> And to imply that I'm a
the Bratz man.
>> The Bratz. >> The man is literally whimpering
directly into the microphone over a joke Hassan, the face of
terrorism in 2025 made. This is 100% performative. You cannot
convince me otherwise. You could pause and play a song to center
yourself, but instead you're staying on stream and whimpering
directly into a microphone
>> after I myself have been twice based on what my father
has done. It's just a little bit crazy, isn't it?
>> He is actually trying to use SA as a shield against
Hassan [__] making jokes about his dad being a convicted
pest. It's the BPD woman meme to say you were sad in order to
be deemed beyond reproach or criticism. Funnily enough, he did
the same thing with Pink when she made allegations against him.
Maybe you're thinking of jumping to conclusions and being too
harsh. Well, just a few minutes later, after that great performance
to garner sympathy from his audience, he switches on a dime like
nothing ever happened. You be the >> But uh yeah, >> dude,
it's so crazy how fast he snaps back, man.
>> That's nuts, dude. >> Be honest. Yikes. >> Yeah,
I don't give a >> Commander and Queef just tipped $3. Don't
forget to subscribe for more content on kick.comjsm.
>> I'm good. >> Yeah, it is what it is.
Anything he can say whatever
>> to be completely honest. Yeah, I think the guy's an
absolute piece of
Do I think he's in the wrong for what he said about my dad? No,
not really. I mean, at the end of the day, those are public court
documents. But try to tie me to that because of who my dad is.
Bro, you're
>> you're just dumb. You know what I mean? Like this whole
apple doesn't fall far from the tree. Don't yourself, dude. We
all know the great guy your dad was. Thankfully, I have a little
bit of class to actually not talk about that.
>> What a joke. >> Uh, anyways, we're going to be
having a podcast with Dan Saltman later,
>> uh, which I bet is going [laughter] to be so great.
This Dan Saltman guy really makes the best friends, doesn't he?
>> That will be happening in 53 minutes. Hassan favorite.
Tech's ex-girlfriend
on Twitter. Tech did a stream together. >> That guy would
not stop talking about how he wanted to have relations with a
podcast member. Made jokes about women. >> This is the
tweet I was looking for. That's the tweet I was looking for.
That's the tweet I was looking for. W Shamu. He's got everything.
He's got everything. I'm going to tell you a story right now
that I've had in my back pocket for a
>> and I want you guys to hear it.
>> Let's go. >> This is alleged because I didn't
hear it from the main source. I heard it from someone very close
to the main source
after me and Emmy broke up.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Tectone one time went to Emy's house
when her parents were there
and allegedly
Tee went to her parents' house,
sat down while she wasn't there and told them that he thinks
that he would be a great boyfriend for her and that he should
date her.
>> And that's cringe. >> When Emmy came home,
>> her parents thought that she was dating
NO, [screaming]
NO, NO.
>> I heard this
>> And that's when Steak and Eggs was cancelled, boys.
That's when they >> I heard it last year. >> Steak
and Eggs is canled [sighs] >> when people didn't all backstab
me and betray me and they were my friends and they told me this
in confidence
>> and then they backstabbed you and betrayed you.
>> Yeah. Emmy knew that Teone was in love with her. We
would talk about it all the >> I'm not dating the microone.
>> We talked about it all the time that Teone was in love
with Emmy. It was weird. He was always obsessed with her. He
would always talk about her in weird ways. It was annoying. Uh
we also knew that he hated me because of it. It was so obvious
to anyone that has a one IQ. That Teto was jealous that I was
dating Evie. Uh that guy would not stop talking about how he
wanted to have relations with a podcast member. I'm guessing
he wanted the Asmin's teeth in. made jokes about women being
raped in Vietnam and made it me extremely uncomfortable. I tried
to say something and was told it wasn't a big deal. >> Wait,
hold on. He knows this is Iron Mike, right? >> Vietnam
and made me extremely uncomfortable. I tried to say something
and was told it wasn't a big deal. He would say the woman who
accused him of SA in the military were liars and I still can't
believe he was allowed around other people.
>> So Pinchu says that Teto knew the entire time and that
the women who accused him of assault in the military were lies.
100% yes. >> So Pink Chu thinks and says that he said it
the entire time, >> including me. The truth always comes
to lie and I hope those women know they did that thing.
>> Mitch Jones with Maya. You unlucky, bro. >> Oh,
that guy saying that >> your dad's
>> that guy saying Mitch Jones was in love with Maya. That's
why he hated on May 9th after returning from traveling abroad
posted an email setting up for >> I'm not a liar. God forbid
a victim stand up for herself insane enough. So just letting
you know during this time period no one wanted to listen to Pinkchu
because uh people said that Pingchu is a dirty only fans and
that's exactly what as uh Tekone portrayed. Perfect. I have you
uh you down for then it would be at the same time place as last
time. Do you need
do you need direction sheet again? Detective special victims
unit Austin Police Department blank blank April 25th. I cannot
share anything else cuz I don't want to jeopardize the investigation.
This is a community I've been dealing with and for my safety
I'm going to be moving on and let the legal system handle it.
So she literally stayed silent for two years. Techone constantly
bered her on stream and said she's a piece of a liar. He uh and
called her a on stream. She went to the police and got a restraining
order. Do you know how hard it is to get a restraining order,
chat? It is so tough to get a restraining order. It's not easy.
It's why I don't have one. >> The doctor. Yeah, he's >> and
she got a restraining order >> and there's way more that
she got. their investigative meetings with the police. Technone's
community, who are obviously biased for their streamer, regularly
accused Pink of faking these screenshots. But don't take her
word
police matters at hand. Take Tech's >> You guys, I'll be
real. I went to the police yesterday. I went to the police yesterday
saying, "Hey, let's hurry this >> I had no idea you could
tell the police, "Let's hurry this up." When they were investigating
you, I'm learning so much, guys. This is awesome. >> Like
legit, I got my lawyers say, "Hey, let's hurry this up, right?"
Cuz like, you know, they're going to investigate me. They're
going to investigate me 100%. They're going to investigate me.
They're going to investigate me 100%. I said, "Bro, bro, just
talk to me. Let's get this go. I've been waiting 7 months for
these people just to reach out to me." And it's like >> interesting.
You waited 7 months for the court stuff to happen. I wonder how
much information and things you possibly did in order to make
sure that you had a solid case, Teone, cuz this is what people
don't understand when they don't go to court. And dumbass who
are getting upset that I'm talking to someone who goes on 4chan
and sent them my lawyer's email don't understand. When it comes
to court, you got to do a lot of work yourself. Court isn't something
you win by your legal team. You have to put in work, especially
as a streamer when you have this big open vat thing. You have
to put in work to make sure that you win the case. Your lawyer,
it doesn't matter if he's uh the the guy that that that uh you
know, the god himself, okay? You have to put in so much work
yourself.
I can't just not put in work. I can't just not try. And we're
trying to do things. You have to do that. How would my lawyer
know about something that happened in 2021 on a deleted VOD on
YouTube? You would not know that exists. Doesn't matter what
lawyer you are. You wouldn't know exist. >> This is tapping
in to all the OTK. >> You have people who know things who
want to help you send you links. >> That's what you got
to do. [laughter] And who knows that? A lot of it is 4chan. And
I'm telling you, a lot of what they send to me, I don't even
look at and it's but a lot of they sent me has actually helped
out a lot and they understand uh what's going on. Uh like because
they just have the video links, they just have tweets.
The most brand dead people who do not know the basics of law.
I know it's so ridiculous how stupid these guys are saying Misk's
talking to Emiru skitsos. When did that guy ever say he was an
Emaru skitso? When did he ever say that he he's he's an Emiru
viewer or an Emaru skitso? He never said that. He messaged me
on Twitter and said, "Yo, I have a lot of stuff from Fortune
I can send
>> Who cares? Who gives a [__]
>> You got to go. >> Can we just go ahead and wrap
genetic
Information is just information.
Do not do not do the genetic fallacy.
>> And then all you ever get told is I recommend you don't
say anything. I recommend you don't say anything. I recommend
you not. >> Let's handle this in court. Let's handle this
in court. Brother, I don't want to. >> Yeah, it's hilarious
how the Skitsos used clips of me from seven years ago on purpose
to portray me as a terrible person. Clips of me from 3 4 5 6
7 8 years ago to portray me as a terrible person. But they're
not skitsos. They're right. They're accurate. They're smart.
They have these things and you don't question if they're weird.
But I'm weird for getting information for my lawsuit.
>> I don't want to do that. I just want to live my life.
That's quite a change from his original threats to sue Pink for
defamation, isn't it? >> You no longer have 2 weeks. You
have 24
>> I mentioned this earlier, but I did speak with Techone.
He said he would answer whatever I wanted. However, once he noticed
the questions, he hid behind the NDA with FEM, even though half
of the questions had nothing to do with her. I asked him about
the allegations and stated earlier he just >> You're all
weird. True, but I'm not going to even put myself in any
I'm sorry. He's just watching video and I think nine friends
out like this receipts as he said he would if there was ever
a period of time where Pink wasn't paying rent and why he wasn't
pursuing a defamation case after he said he would. He responded
with I think the problem with a lot of these questions is that
with an ongoing lawsuit happening I think you know I can't talk
about a lot of this out of curiosity to not feel any fire. Wouldn't
it just be better to wait to make this video until the result
of the investigation or why does it need to be made now? He's
trying to make tech. He's trying to make uh this guy not make
a video because he doesn't want this guy to uh make it because
he's hoping that he just completely forgets about it and moves
on. But this guy didn't and he made a godlike video that I cannot
believe only has 47,000
views. That blows my mind. This video is so good. I cannot believe
I didn't know about this video. >> The guy is lowkey asked
me not to make this video.
So that's how I take it. After he answers none, I asked which
ongoing lawsuit to which I received no answer and asked again
the next day if he was referring to the NDA
and again received no answer. The thing is none of those questions
I asked had anything to do with his NDA with Free. They were
all concerning Pink. In conclusion, I would say in the public
discourse we judge these controversies that aren't definitively
proven on the character of the parties involved.
We know Frame was going to come out with >> We also judged
on the fact that Techone has a big wide audience and people around
him that will defend him till the end of time and big big content
creators that will watch his videos and and and push him with
a a massive audience which they gave him for YouTube. Um and
these content creators won't talk
>> accusations now. >> Meanwhile, Pink Chu is just
a small Instagram girl who had no real following and and just
did only fans >> 100% based on obtained and that Tech has
consistently lied about this for years. When Pink and Teone got
word of these allegations, they went absolutely >> She
was going to do something much worse. So bad it would have ruined
all of our lives. >> They defamed Frame with cheating allegations
to explain Tecton's behavior, which we now know is false, with
receipts. They also knowingly or unknowingly filed a false police
report against her for revenge. Pink sues Frame, which from what
we have available is filled with Technone's stories and interactions
with Frame, which I conclude him participating in feeding info
for Pink's lawsuit. He denies encouraging Pink, but we have proof
of him participating. Pink gets cheated on. Tone lies about the
breakup date to avoid responsibility and receives her posted
proving him wrong and showing Pink saying she was scared of him.
Pink accuses Teone of abuse. Her story hasn't wavered and currently
there is an ongoing police investigation. According to both Pink
and Teone, >> there's not anything ongoing now. It's over
and he lost. >> Teone says he can prove it. >> I
saw so many people trying to defend Tech saying that it's a civil
suit
cuz he's a liar and he abuses women. his innocence with her.
He might just be misunderstanding this a little bit on paying
rent, which he later gets caught lying about.
>> I really think when I had a video of him walking outside
of court that that wasn't proof that Teone was in a court case,
we literally also have proof that Teone was in court. It's it's
it's public. It's public that Teone got his restraining order
upgraded because of what they found in his phone and from his
files and what he's [clears throat] been doing. the it was so
bad that he has a protective order chat. A restraining order
is already hard to get. To get a restraining order, chat, you
have to do some pretty dog things to someone. Calling them non-stop,
harassing them nonstop, following them around, bothering them,
making their lives miserable to get a restraining order. You
want to know why it's so hard to get a restraining order? Because
when you have a restraining order on you, you have to abide by
that by your life. When you go on planes, they check that. They
>> people will come here for like the strict facts
for the followot
or at least how long the protective order is for the tails w
you a protective order is an upgraded version of a restraining
order
so hard to get.
>> It's so hard to get. >> Honestly, it's really
annoying because the reality is she doesn't pay. >> Tech
threatens to sue Pink for defamation and saber rattles, but when
she doesn't retract, >> they hand out TR to women like
Candy. Well, if you're going to make that logic, it's interesting
why I don't have that. cla
it's just not every I know so many women that have had real real
stalkers and real freaks of nature that tried to go get a
a restraining order and it took years to get. It's not some simple
thing. It's really hard to get and they had to provide a proof
to get that restraining order. It's not something they just get
neary by just their hands up. It's it's >> This is Msk.
This is me. Just because he isn't named doesn't mean he can't
be
to this day. He has yet to file a defamation case against me.
I while making a video on Teone reached out to which he responded
saying he will answer any of my question. >> This guy destroys
Tech. I mean he really
into this. I consider Teone a liar and a manipulator of his audience
spinning stories to attempt to escape the smallest of controversy
such as cheating to the more extreme lying in the case of his
response to allegations against Pink and how he spun the rent
situation. I began making this video over the absurdity of his
father's infamous rap coupled with his own allegations and came
away with revelations of his ex-wife alleging abuse that led
to false police reports, lies, and lawsuits in response to this
abuse potentially becoming public. This coupled with the ex-girlfriend's
abuse allegations are a catastrophic combination for Teone. It
is the consistent lying and content of character of the parties
involved which should lead people to look at the story again
with all the events and timeline in front of you to consider.
That being said, cheers everyone and thanks for
Godlike video.
>> I don't know how this thing didn't get any more views
than this, but godlike video. Uh J JS link this video as >> godlike
video.
>> Godlike video.